Try to keep this a about a fist away
from your face.
The best length.
This a little closer.
If you can have a good,
we're live.
Oh,
that was quick.
you're,
you're a wizard over there,
Mr Blum.
Yes.
Chow man.
I appreciate it.
Well,
we were in a film together so we've been
like right next to each other on
cellulite.
Let someone we in that was the culture.
Hi Brett Harvey.
And it's a you,
me,
Richard Branson and snoop Dogg.
Oh,
good company.
Yes.
Right.
Yeah.
So,
um,
well you were just saying right before
we did the podcast,
you were in bed for 15 years.
I was,
I got sick in 1988.
I wasn't able to make it out of that bed
until 2003.
But Joe,
I was absolutely certain I would never
make it out of that bed.
What did you have?
It's called these days.
This month it's called a m e cfs.
Uh,
up until now it was just known as
chronic fatigue syndrome cfs.
But it's real serious if you get a bad
case of it.
So I was too weak to talk for five years
too weak to talk.
You didn't talk at all?
Not a bit.
I didn't have the strength to puff out
even a syllable.
Um,
and um,
I was too weak to have another person in
the room with me for five years so I
don't have a person in the room.
My stress levels were off the charts and
the slightest thing would just the
crack.
My wife tried to keep me company so we
have this big king size bed and she
would lay in bed reading a newspaper and
the sound of the page turning went
through me like a cannon ball and she,
it just tore me to pieces and she had to
build a separate room in the front of
the house and live there because I
couldn't tolerate anything.
Did you think it was over?
Yeah.
I thought first of all,
something you don't know,
you have a sense of humanity and you
don't know it and something like this
that wipes out your entire future.
Every dream,
the overhead for yourself robs you of
your sense of humanity and you don't
know.
There is a sense of humanity until it
disappears.
So it took me three years.
I had to rebuild a personality from just
about scratch.
Wow.
Because of the one area I could handle
at least most of the time was the
internet.
You know,
the Internet hit the music industry in
1983 and I had been lusting after it for
years because only academics had access
to this real high tech thing.
And um,
I had,
it took me three years to realize that
every day I was trying to go up to my
front room office and work.
And that sitting was draining me of my
energy.
And since I only had a tiny amount of
energy,
if I lay there horizontal in the bed,
my voice eventually come back.
So I had an assistant take two computers
because in those days to computers was
about half the size.
The processing power was half the size
of your cell phone.
And I had them hook up two computers and
a Chinese box.
Don't let anybody tell you the Chinese
and Chinese don't event things they do.
And this was a box that allowed me to
control both computers from one monitor
and one keyboard.
So we have the keyboard up on foam
bolsters so that I could see it when I
was laying perfectly horizontal in bed
so I could still see the keys.
And I rebuilt a personality online cause
I couldn't get any further than to the
bathroom and back.
That was it.
What do you mean by you rebuilt a
personality?
Well,
everything I hadn't expected.
I mean I was going to write my first
book and I was gonna I,
I'm a nerd from science.
I got into science at the age of 10 I
got into theoretical physics and
microbiology.
I felt built my first Boolean Algebra
machine when I was 12 I code is on a
computer that won science fair awards.
When I was 12 I was taken to see the
head of the graduate physics department
at the University of Buffalo and
disappeared into his office for an hour.
My mother wondered what in the world
that happened to me cause it was
supposed to be a five minute courtesy
call.
We were discussing big bang versus
steady state theory of the universe for
an hour and a half.
When I was 16 I worked at the world's
largest cancer research lab and I came
up with the theory of the beginning,
middle and end of the universe,
the Big Bang theory or the bloom tour,
a little model that predicted 38 years
in advanced dark energy.
And then I ended up in the rock and roll
business with this background.
So when I imagined I was going to write
my first book,
I was going to leave the rock and roll
business behind because my field
expedition and rock and roll,
I'd learned,
I thought as much as I was ever going to
learn from it.
And I'd worked with Michael Jackson,
Prince Bob Marley,
bette Midler,
ACDC Aerosmith,
kiss,
Kiss Queen,
Billy Joel,
billy idol,
Paul Simon,
Peter Gabriel,
David Byrne,
people like that.
What?
What caused this disease?
Like nobody knows.
Nobody knows.
Nobody has a clue what the,
so in the different names,
chronic fatigue syndrome and ease.
I would just send me a Myalgic
encephalomyelitis and more dignified
name do can they understand it into the
point where they could test for it.
Did they give you a blood test or they
just can't test for it?
They don't know what causes it.
There's no Ivrit.
A friend approached me at one point and
said,
the Duchess of Kent has what you have.
Can you write her a letter about how to
manage it?
So instead of a letter I wrote 14 or 16
pages or something like that.
So when people have this,
I send them this pamphlet that explains
how I got out of it,
but we'll work for me is not necessarily
gonna work for you or anybody else.
Was it a gradual slipping away of your
energy or was it a back gradual?
It happened on March 10th of 1988 so
March 9th you're fine.
March 10th March 9th I'm fine.
March 10th I'm fine.
I fly down to a,
I think it was richmond or something
like that to go out.
Five to be taken by jeep,
uh,
five hours into the countryside to meet
with Linda Womack.
That's Sam Cooke's daughter and her
husband,
uh,
Cecil Womack who is broke the rolling
stones first hit,
he and his brother and they have this
big aircraft hanger sized farm building.
Uh,
it's going to be their home,
but right now they've just had it built.
It's empty,
it doesn't have heating yet and it's
March 10th.
It's still the end of winter.
And so we go and pass the sheep and into
this building and there's no furniture
in there.
And I sit there and interview them for
five hours and find out that there's
something called a black coal mining
culture.
And the Gospel came out of those black
coal mines.
I had no idea that blacks ever got
involved in coal mines,
much less that.
That's how gospel culture began.
And I,
they drove me five hours back to the
airport again.
I sat there on the plane with my little
trs,
100,
the very first laptop computer,
this little Gizmo that ran off of Aa
batteries and um,
and then I forgot my,
my laptop.
On the plane.
I don't do things like that.
Some of that was a little off the next
day I thought I had a cold.
My technique for handling a cold work
your fucking ass off.
Um,
walk a minimum of two and a half miles
and do your work.
So I worked in power to my way through
it by Tuesday.
Um,
I was so weak that my staff had a pick
me up under the armpits and drag me off
to the elevator and throw me in the back
of a car service car and shipped me out
to parks slope to my brownstone in
Brooklyn.
Guy.
Don't know how I even got up the stairs
and it was all downhill basically from
there for 15 years.
15 freaking years.
Right.
But so,
but I still had,
I had gotten halfway through writing my
first book.
My plan was,
okay,
I'll do what I've done with all my rock
and roll bands when my book is ready to
come out.
I'll go do every morning television
show,
every radio show,
every newspaper in the country.
I'll stay at high houses where the
sheets are sunny and yellow and um,
where they make the bed for you.
You don't have to make it yourself and
they'll feed you food and stuff like
that.
And I'll promote my book.
That was my vision of my next step in
life.
My Future.
Well,
if you can't leave your bedroom,
that's all gone.
That's all gone.
And you have to,
and I had to walk into my office one day
and say,
I have no idea of what's happening to
me.
I could be dying.
I have to be out of here in two weeks.
And um,
I gave the whole thing to my staff,
the biggest pr firm in the music
industry.
He just gave it to them.
Yeah.
And the next day I got a call from a
west coast competitor offering me a lot
of money and I had to say,
no,
I'm sorry.
I gave it to my staff yesterday.
So,
and,
and I say how to reinvent myself with
what little I had.
The books were still a value.
My science was still a value and I had
to create a new me online.
Now when you see create a new you online
and you say create a new personality,
what do you,
what exactly do you mean by that?
Well,
I out with your old personality,
old personality,
couldn't walk anymore,
couldn't talk anymore.
Your body.
That was my body.
But you have no idea of just how much of
your personality is your body and your
vocal cords and stuff like that that you
take for granted are instruments of some
internal you I had to invent an
existence,
let's put it that way.
Um,
online.
And how'd you do that?
Like when you say,
well,
I got on,
I got on line.
Um,
first I,
God,
I can't even remember what came first,
but at some point,
um,
because I was fact checking my first
book,
but how to do this all laying there in
bed.
Um,
I got hold of Napoleon,
Sean [inaudible],
who is the,
the anthropologist who chronicled the
fierce people,
the Auto Mama in South America.
People who are really,
I mean you,
the more people you kill,
the more wives you get.
It's as simple as that.
And Ya know,
I'm old culture and um,
I wanted him to read my book,
my first book,
the Lucifer principle of scientific
expedition into the forces of history.
And he said,
look,
people are out to destroy my career
right now.
I can't get involved with anything
controversial but I a key member of the
human behavior and evolution society and
you should be a member.
While he introduced me to a social group
in which I could interact as long as I
can continue to type.
So this is a message board or um,
it was all done via email.
So just a,
a group of people that you could
interact with with him.
And I've been working on my writing
since I was 16 years old.
Science is my base,
but the book I got at the age of 12 by
Albert Einstein,
you know,
sometimes a book grabs you by the lapels
and it feels like the author's writing
this directly into your face.
And Einstein said to be a genius.
It's not enough to come over,
come up with a theory.
Only seven men in the world can
understand to be a genius who have to be
able to come up with that theory and
then express it so clearly that anyone
with a high school education and a
reasonable degree of intelligence can
understand it.
So Albert Einstein,
my heroes said,
schmuck,
listen up.
You want to be on an original scientific
thinker?
You have to be the best writer you can
possibly be.
So I had been working on my writing
since I was 16 years old.
I was late.
[inaudible] took me four years to get
around to doing it.
After Einstein gave me the orders,
and I'm one when I was put on the human
behavior and evolutionary society group,
well,
I can write my fucking ass off.
So people were impressed and they
gathered around me.
Fortunate.
Now admittedly it's all on a computer
screen and it's all via keyboard and
there are no living humans in the room
and he applies.
But it's saved my life to be able to do
that.
And then I found it to international
scientific groups of my own and I wrote
three books because those were things I
could do with that keyboard as long as I
have the strength to do the keyboarding
and I didn't always have the strength to
even lift my hands and do that,
but I did most of the time.
Now during this time were you getting
treated?
Were doctors giving you doctors don't
know a damn thing about this?
Eventually,
my first wife who I lost because of this
lost a 34 year marriage because of the
illness.
She persuaded a cfs doctor or a doctor
who specializes in chronic fatigue
syndrome to come out to my house when he
was going to a party in Brooklyn and see
me and the most useful thing that he did
was hand me a piece of paper with an
email address on it and he said,
this is another one of my patients.
She's in Texas.
I want you to get in touch with her.
And the two of us went out like Hansel
and Gretel,
holding hands going into the forest,
looking for treatment modalities.
We're looking for treatments that might
possibly save us from our illness.
So when I tell people this stuff,
I take it and they say,
okay,
who can I get this room?
And I send them to my doctor,
my old cfs doctor.
He says,
oh,
I don't give those treatments.
Well he gave them to me,
but he gave them to me because those
were the things that felt like they
might work and he allowed me to try
them.
And I ended up with a,
every morning I give myself a shot with
three different things in it,
a half a cc of magnesium,
one cc of Oxytocin,
and a about two CC's of Santa Cobalamin,
which is liquid vitamin B's 12 so b12
magnesium and oxytocin.
Oxytocin,
the bonding hormone,
oxytocin,
the stuff that creates trust in
neuroeconomics experiments.
Oxytocin with,
if you're a mother and you've just given
birth to a baby,
when you put that baby to your left
nipple for the very first time,
you feel in some cases like you've just
taken lsd because this chemical goes
coursing through your body and it's a
trip and it makes you trust everybody.
In the room and everybody who walks into
the room,
it's oxytocin and oxytocin.
I've been on oxytocin now for 20 years
and Oxytocin,
it turns out also does something else.
Um,
there's this little experiment called
parabiosis taken old rat.
His brain is aging is hard as aging.
His kidneys are aging.
You Hook up the circulatory system to
the circulatory system of a young rat.
And guess what starts happening to the
old rat.
His brain starts,
we're versing getting,
getting younger.
His heart starts getting younger.
His kidneys start to get younger.
So I'm about to be 75 years old in a
month.
And um,
I do between 400 and 700 pushups in the
morning.
First thing,
that's crazy.
That's really crazy.
But when they tried to figure out what
is reversing the aging and the muscles
of the rat,
the heart of the rat,
the brain of the rat,
the one ingredient they were able to
isolate and then use on other rats to
get them to get younger instead of older
was oxytocin.
So in all probability,
the reason I can do between 400 and 700
pushups in the morning at the age of 74
and when I was 19,
the most I could do was 92 and I was
working really hard at it.
Um,
is the oxytocin,
so never heard of anybody taking that as
a supplement?
Well,
it showed up.
There was a doctor named something like
seastrunk in Texas who was using it on
cfs patients.
And my friend,
the Texas patient of my doctor,
um,
found seastrunk and got his protocol out
of him.
In other words,
exactly what he'd used to treat the
problem.
And we gave it to my doctor and he sat
on it for six months until he could
regurgitate it as a own bright idea.
And then,
and then he prescribed it for me and
it's done wonders that,
and a bunch of other stuff have done
absolute wonders of the other things
that have worked.
I think Gabapentin without that,
I mean,
I was on my way to Moscow once I finally
got out of bed,
I was going to address an international
conference of quantum physicists.
About why everything they know about
quantum physics is wrong.
And I was fine.
All,
I mean this was my first traveling since
I'd gotten out of bed and it was taking
a huge chance cause it was a huge chance
on throwing me back into bed again.
And I flew all the way to Germany and
was doing just fine.
I was exhilarated that I was doing so
well.
And then halfway between Germany and
Moscow,
the cfs symptoms began to come back and
that was scary.
And then I reviewed what I was doing and
I realized I had missed all my afternoon
pills and I,
and as soon as I was able,
well we had to find a,
a bed in the infirmary,
which is scary.
And the Moscow airport,
because there are people walking around
with machine guns and military uniforms
and they want to take my passport away
in order to allow me to lay in a bed in
the infirmary.
And so I could be disappeared at any
second.
But when we finally got to our hotel and
opened up my drug role,
um,
I took the Gabapentin and within 15
minutes of the symptoms were going,
wow.
So did,
have you ever tried to isolate
individual ones?
It removes some of them from the
protocol to see if I once removed one
amytriptolene it's an antidepressant.
That's what it was originally designed
for and I figured I don't need this
anymore.
I'm perfectly healthy.
It was a big mistake.
I started having these blinding stomach
aches and they went out for a low,
I mean for months and months and months
until I finally got fed up and started
researching on Google.
What do you do about summer cakes?
Well,
guess one of the primary things you do
to stop stomach cases,
amitriptyline,
the very thing I had gone off of,
so I had to go back on it.
So it's a whole network,
a mesh of supplements,
drugs and lifestyle.
I don't sleep the way normal people
sleep.
I sleep from four o'clock in the morning
until eight o'clock in the morning.
I get up.
I listened to magazines on the kindle
while I'm taking my bath and shaving and
all that stuff.
I meet with my assistant,
I give her her marching orders for the
day.
I go back to sleep at 11 and I sleep
until three,
and then I get up for my second work
day.
Um,
and that's when I do all my writing and
all that kind of stuff.
So you do,
you sleep in four hour chunks while you
four hour chunks because that is better
for you.
My body was refusing to do the eight
hour thing.
So one of the first symptoms of,
of cfs is in Somnia.
Okay.
Now Joe,
if your body is refusing to sleep for
eight hours straight,
listen to your body,
give it what the hell it wants.
And so these are the hours my body
demanded.
Um,
and they,
I had been working often until eight
o'clock in the morning from roughly 11
o'clock at night or something like that
and losing track of time and it was very
disorienting.
And once I started this two periods of
sleep a day,
my day stabilized.
Um,
and there's other stuff.
I mean listening to Pandora,
you would think,
what does that have to do with your
illness?
Well,
I work at a cafe.
That's a vital part of things because
I'm surrounded by people and I've slowly
build community in this cafe,
other workaholic writers like me,
a neuroscientist,
a novel novelist,
and all kinds of people who just sit
there and slave away all day.
And,
but I'm listening to Pandora that gives
me a sense of life.
For some reason.
It's as it's as positive as an elixir
would be.
Um,
and it gives me a sense of control over
my environment.
And I don't hear the conversations going
on around me so I can really focus on my
work.
I've written four books this way so far
in cafes,
all of this stuff walking five miles a
day.
I'm in two bursts.
I mean,
there I am going through a meadow in the
middle of a park at night.
Uh,
how many New Yorkers do you know who go
out and walk through a park in the
middle of the night?
Rob's,
yeah,
right.
That's what you'd think.
But I have the time of my life looking
up at the stars at Lynn middle of the
meadow and being where I'm not supposed
to be and not supposed to go through the
park at night.
Well they let you.
Um,
I had been thrown up six times by the
police because I've overseen,
I've overstepped the boundaries.
I've been out there after one o'clock
and they do close the place at one and
throw us all out.
But no,
in New York Lore,
unless you're walking a really big dog,
you do not go out into parks at night
and,
but do you put this whole lifestyle
together and it's not just any
individual ingredient that's making me
better.
I'm happier than I was when I was 19.
I'm stronger than I walk a lot more
slowly than when I was 19.
But in terms of push ups and other
exercises,
I'm stronger than I was when I was 19
years old.
That is a crazy journey,
Howard.
That's crazy.
And it's only a part.
I mean,
right now I'm co-designing.
So here I hurry.
I'm the guy who worked with Michael
Jackson,
Prince Bob Marley and all of those
people.
And I'm co-designing a multiplanetary
mission at Caltech right now.
I'm out here in California to do a
bookstore reading my first one on the
west coast for how I accidentally
started the 60s my current book.
But then I have three presentations at
the annual meeting of the National Space
Society and I'm on the board of
governors of the National Space Society
and I've got some important things to do
there.
And then they let me sit on the board
meetings.
I'm used to be on both the board and the
Board of governors and uh,
there are some important things I need
to help this group accomplish.
And then I go back to New York and get,
hopefully,
if I'm lucky and my planes are on time,
I get to New York in time to get some
sleep and to get up and do an interview
with a British
filmmaker who's making a film about
Prince.
And meantime,
there's a film being made about my life
called surf the catastrophe.
It's a 60 to 90 minute film and they
finally getting,
after a year of shooting,
they're getting down to the editing and
it's a three time grammy winner who is
my director and one of the camera who's
been with us through this whole thing.
Um,
a couple of Sundays ago,
my director got his first or his third
grammy,
our Emmy and my,
uh,
one of my cameramen got his second emmy.
So there's all kinds of wild stuff.
I have 15 projects going on at once.
I love that.
Yeah.
I was going to say that it seems like
you get very energized when you talking
about the amount of different things
that you're doing all at once.
Yeah.
It's just that part of what gives you
juice.
Yeah.
Because,
uh,
for whatever reason,
if I refuse to go into any niche,
I refuse to go into one specialization
and see the walls close in on me and get
buried there.
And my goal since I was 16 years old and
working at the world's largest cancer
research facility has been not to be a
mole digging a hole so deep you can't
see anything.
Um,
but to be the eagle flying over the
landscape and taking each of those mole
holes as pick pixels in a big picture.
So I do all the sciences that termed
autod Dec.
Yes.
Autodidact.
Well,
I read two books a day from the time I
was 10,
and by the time I got to college I
remember I'm there with the,
at the age of 12 with the head of the
graduate physics department,
not just the physics department,
the graduate physics department,
and we're talking as equals,
which is really weird.
So pretty weird.
So by the time I got to college,
I ended up with four fellowships in
neuroscience.
I realized that for me,
graduate school would be the Auschwitz
of the mind.
Um,
I felt I was in a box car on my way to
the end of everything I wanted to
understand in life.
Why is that?
Well,
because since I was 12 or 13 years old,
I want it to take all the panorama,
the full pallet of the sciences,
and I wanted to use them among other
things to understand ecstatic
experiences.
I wanted to understand how Hitler put
together this performance torchlight
parades where 15 guys are walking down
the streets abreast of each other,
carrying torches at 10 o'clock at night,
and people on the [inaudible] van
Linden,
the big boulevard are packed so tight
that if you pulled up your feet,
you wouldn't topple over because the
crowd would hold you up.
They were crowded in on.
I was a side of you supporting you and
people had a sense of being lifted out
of themselves and having a transcendent
experience and becoming part of three
things.
I invoke one tribe.
I write one state,
I'm fewer her one leader,
but it gave them,
we all need a sense of being a part of
something bigger than ourselves.
I wanted to know how that sense of
ecstatic disillusion into something
bigger than yourself happens.
Do you think that we're in Hitler's case
that this was an accident?
No.
I think Hitler,
I think designed this was,
yes,
he did design it.
He absolutely,
he knew that he could create this sort
of ecstatic state and in these people,
you bet.
Um,
he was an exotic and he was preaching to
people to bring them to a state of
ecstasy.
How did he know all this?
How did he know?
All of us,
all this the way any artist knows how to
achieve things that he may never have
seen,
achieved before in his life.
It's intuition.
We're all built with certain,
uh,
super normal responses inside of us.
Certain gushes of emotion you can hit if
you hit just the right stimulus.
And he hired Albert speer to be as art
directors.
So Albert speer would art direct these
massive events like this,
but it was Hitler who would go into a
state of ecstatic preaching as if
preaching in tongues,
but preaching in one tongue,
German.
And who could bring that audience to
that ecstatic level?
Um,
he was disturb you to study someone as
fucked up as Hitler though,
and look for the genius in his approach,
especially as it chooses.
Yeah.
You Bet your ass.
Yeah,
of course.
Um,
but I figure if Hitler could use this
for evil,
the big trick is to understand it and
use it for good.
And in fact,
it turns out that a rock concert has
these ecstatic elements in it.
And you know,
you hear about audiences getting off.
That's what the put people stage are
constantly trying to achieve.
That's an ecstatic state.
Is this what was fascinating to you
about rock in the first place that led
you to become a publicist?
Right.
Because remember,
if I'd gone to Grad School,
I would have been giving paper and
Pencil tests to 22 college students in
exchange for one psychology credit.
Now,
how much was I going to learn about mass
x disease?
The forces of history in that college
costs?
Not saying that you,
you had this foresight because for many
people,
the idea of going to Grad school and
becoming a professor like that was the,
that was the golden pot at the end of
the rainbow.
And everybody knew I was going to be a
college professor from the time I was 10
years old.
But the closer I got to it,
the more I realize that this is like
being put in a sardine can and having
the cam welded over you.
Um,
it's,
it's a big mistake.
And,
and I,
I started a commercial art studio with a
bunch of artists that I had worked with.
I,
one day I was in class,
I was,
I was very serious about poetry,
poetry set a lot of the tones.
It taught me how to lead a life.
I mean,
the love song of j l for proof rock says
shmuck listen up the way that Einstein,
except he doesn't,
I mean,
he's an antisemite,
so he's not going to say Schumacher ts
Elliot.
But he said,
listen up.
If you don't start doing the,
the heroic stuff that you feel will
divine,
will define you and bring young women
crawling to your ankles and kissing your
knees.
If you don't,
if you have that in you,
that vision of what you want to be and
you don't start it now today,
this hour,
you will put it off and put it off and
put it off.
And when you hit the age of 50,
you'll suddenly realize you don't have
the life force.
You don't have the life energy to do
that anymore.
And your whole life will have been a
failure.
So if you have something heroic to do,
start it now.
So I was in a poetry class cause poetry
had had a huge influence on my life.
And one day the poetry teacher,
the poet and residents in Nyu said,
bloom when everybody leaves the
classroom,
close the door.
I need to talk to,
well that doesn't sound good.
And he said,
okay.
He sat me in the balling out chair and
he said,
look,
you,
last year I asked you to be on the staff
of the literary magazine.
You never even showed up this year.
I'm telling you,
you are the literary magazine.
The minute you walk out that door,
your it,
you don't even have a faculty adviser
now get out the door.
So I turned it into an experimental
graphics and literary magazine.
So I knew a bunch of artists and one of
them was being thrown out of his
apartment and it was the beginning of
the summer.
Um,
his electricity was about to be cut off,
his phone was about to be caught off and
his furniture gallery being repossessed.
He and his wife and child were sitting
on a bear rug floor crying when I walked
in and I said,
look,
you're a bloody genius.
Give me your portfolio.
I'll take it out for two weeks.
Uh,
I'll get you work.
That'll get the,
allow you to pay your rent and then I
can move on and get a proper summer job.
While it didn't turn out to be that
easy,
by the end of the summer,
I hadn't gotten a single job.
I got in New York magazine,
addressed it and doing a feature on my
art studio,
but I hadn't gotten the artists and the
other artists in the studio a single
job.
And I'm an obsessive compulsive,
so I call Columbia where I was supposed
to go to Grad school and said,
um,
you know,
I have a back problem.
I won't be showing up this year.
Joe.
The truth at any price,
including the price of your life,
is one of my religious principles.
It's the first rule of science.
The second rule of science is look at
things right under your nose,
noses,
if you've never seen them before.
And then proceed from there.
The truth at any price,
including the price of your life.
Yeah.
So when people tell me,
for example about my book,
the Mohammad Code,
how it desert profit brought you isis,
al Qaeda in Boko Haram or Hama Hama and
met and Jihad.
So when people realized I was writing
this,
they said,
you can't write that you'll get killed.
Who the fuck cares?
The first rule of science is the truth
and any price,
including the price of your life.
And if you tell me I can't write it
cause it's gonna get me killed,
I know that it's doubly important for me
to write this because nobody else is
going to have the guts to.
So the,
it falls on me.
So screw that.
Um,
you seem to be approaching all these
different things,
whether it is sitting in the cafe
listening to music,
being surrounded by people,
poetry,
uh,
the,
the goal,
the ecstatic state that you were
studying when it comes to Hitler or
rocks,
rock music.
You're seem to be looking at this as
almost like a form of a,
not necessarily uncharted energy but uh,
undocumented as almost as if it's like
there's a,
there's fuel out there that you are,
you're tapping into and utilizing that,
you know,
that everybody's kind of aware of.
But I don't think they're thinking about
it the same way that you are.
No,
when I'm looking at this in the context
of everything from the big bang to
what's going on in our brains while
we're having this conversation in the
future,
you and I are fashioning through our
actions at this point.
I'm looking at this in terms of very,
very,
very big picture and,
and I get disturbed when it looks like
I'm going to get typed.
Like I've spent so much time on,
on space in the last few years that I'm
afraid people are going to type me.
And I refuse to be typed as the space
guy.
Yeah.
Because I need to have access to every
field that I can possibly understand
because I'm in the process of putting
together a big picture.
When you say you worried about being,
I mean,
after all you've accomplished,
how could you be tight?
Oh,
it's real easy.
But by who?
But it partly by myself but also by
others.
Interesting.
By yourself.
Yeah.
You're worried about yourself.
I,
yes,
I absolutely.
In order to be happy I need to be in a
dozen simultaneously.
That's fascinating.
I am much less intense about it,
but I share a similar desire to be
fascinated by many different things at
the same time.
And you've got to see where they all fit
together.
That's the real trick.
And,
and the real,
and the tool for this,
for me,
when I was 12 years old,
my parents,
I'd never paid attention in school.
I read two books a day.
That's it.
So I read a book on under the desk
teacher who cared about the teacher,
um,
and my parents were going to send me off
to a small private school.
But they made me promise to,
to work in school.
I'd never worked in school before and I
forget where I was going with this
story,
but,
but there is one experience I had in
this little high school.
It's really relevant and that is okay by
the time I'm 16 years old,
I'm going to after the ecstatic
experience for four years in scientific
terms,
when I'm 14 and here about a book called
the varieties of the religious
experience by William James.
I spend four months looking for a copy
of the book because there is no Amazon
yet.
Um,
and finding books in buffalo isn't that
easy.
Um,
and then I'm 16 and I've been elected
the head of the program committee and my
school,
the program committee,
this every day starts for the entire
student body with a 45 minute morning
session.
And I mc those sessions and I program
two of them.
So the juniors come to me and they say,
could we were having a dance?
Could you please advertise our dance for
us?
And they don't understand the irony of
what they've just ask.
If there's a dance anywhere in Buffalo,
New York.
People want me to park my feet
elsewhere,
preferably in Cleveland or Houston,
Texas.
Um,
and so this is really weird request.
So I put a piece of music on the
turntable behind the stage and I get up
on the stage and I'm incompetent.
I can't dance.
I mean,
I spent a year in dance class.
My parents were trying to make me
normal,
didn't work.
Um,
and,
but I dance and it's not like any dance
you've ever seen before in your life.
And I see the girl who hates me most,
I see her pupils start to dilate.
And then I see all of the pupils,
350 sets of pupils,
700 eyeballs dilating.
And then I see their faces melting.
And then it feels as if their energy
coalesces like a big Amoeba and reaches
out a pseudopod in the pseudopod sends
itself through me.
And the energy goes up through me as if
I were an empty pipe,
reaches something just above my head.
And His transmogrified utterly
transformed and goes back down to the
audience again in a continuous feedback
loop.
And I have an auto body experience.
I'm convinced that I'm on the ceiling
watching all of this happen,
that I'm not under under any control
from me.
I'm in control of this energy.
And finally when it's all over,
remember these kids do not like me in
this school.
Not at all.
And,
and they do something as if they have
practiced it all their lives.
And I know for a fact they have never
done it before.
They surged down to the foot of the
stage.
They pick me up on their shoulders,
they carry me out of the auditory.
They carry me up the walkway to the
building above where we have our
classes.
And then they put me down.
They never did it before.
They never did it afterward.
Not for football stars,
not for anything.
That's a scene in a movie.
Well,
I mean it might be.
What is that for me?
I then after,
well,
I've been the,
after the ecstatic experience by then at
that,
that the carves,
the forces of history for four years of
my bloody life.
What did you think you tapped into?
Did you,
did you think you had somehow another
manifested this?
No,
I,
I knew I tacked into a part of me that's
in there.
I mean,
well,
my parents tried to drag me off.
Look,
I,
I have,
we're going back in time.
Let's go back to when I was about to be
13 years old.
Okay.
And,
uh,
and I realized sometime when I was 12
and a half years old that I was an
atheist.
I didn't believe in God.
12 and a half.
Yeah.
Why,
why 12 and a half at 12?
No idea.
I have six months.
It took me two and a half years of
reading two books a day.
So at,
but I,
you know,
you can sometimes park something just
out of consciousness and a closet of
your mind and keep it there.
So I kept it there because I didn't want
to miss out on the precedence for my bar
Mitzvah.
And plus it was the only party I was
ever going to be invited to my own Bar
Mitzvah party.
Right.
Who could write you gotta kiss is that,
yeah.
So it wasn't until after the Bar Mitzvah
was over and all of the thank you notes
had been written a sale.
I was able to,
to admit that I'm an atheist,
so that means that I,
my bar Mitzvah was in June by the time
I'm finished with all the thank you
notes,
it's August.
Well,
what's just around the corner September
and in the Jewish calendar that high
holidays.
So my parents tried to drag me off to
high holidays and they get me as far as
the street that the synagogue is on.
And then I refused to go any further and
as,
yeah,
well not by now it's 13.
Okay.
And um,
so I'm hanging on to these sturdily
American craftsmen built doors of the
fraser blue car.
My Dad drives and my parents are at my
ankles trying,
spreading my socks,
trying to pull me up toward the
synagogue.
And I have a sudden realization Galileo
had his insights by taking these new
fangled devices called lenses,
putting them in a tube and pointing the
tube,
which was designed to be used for
horizontal viewing.
So you could see an army coming over the
horizon towards you long before they
could see you.
He takes this tube and he turns it in a
totally unexpected direction up.
And another guy,
Anton van Leeuwenhoek who uses the same
high tech devices,
lenses cause he's a draper,
he sells fabric.
So he uses his magnifying glass to see
how tight the weavers and as fabric.
And his great innovation is to take
these lenses and turn down and look at
pond water and look at his own sperm.
Um,
and I suddenly had this realization why
parents are shredding my socks and
trying to drag me up to the synagogue.
There are no gods in the heavens.
There are no gods beneath the earth.
So where are the gods right now in this
scene?
There in my parents and they are,
are tugging with astonishing force at my
parents and my socks.
And if there,
if the gods or in my parents,
then the gods are in me too.
So my task in life is going to be to
take that lens that Galileo churned up
and that van Leeuwenhoek turned down and
turn it within to find the gods inside
of us,
meaning finding those ecstatic
experiences and that dance experience
was the most primal of these ecstatic,
you could call them spiritual
experiences,
but for me it's sexual,
sexual,
secular,
sorry,
spirituality.
I got sex on the brain.
But that was the,
that was the closest I was going to get
to what Hitler had summon forth.
Those speeches that Hitler gave,
I don't understand German,
but there the intensity that he was
giving these speeches out,
and I've seen this before with radical
Islam speakers or with,
you know,
many different religious leaders.
There's something about what they're
doing that is,
it's almost contagious.
Like you,
you,
you see whatever there,
the energy that they're putting out,
it's so compelling.
It's,
it's a bizarre thing that human beings
have this,
this compulsion to pay attention to
people that have achieved this extreme
level of performance.
Well because they seen locked into a
truth.
That truth speaks to itself through
every muscle of their body.
Confident,
right?
Like the preacher on stage shouting out
to the heavens.
And if you're that confident to have
that much energy and conviction,
there must be some truth to what you're
saying
and there is a good chance that you are
having a kind of out of body experience
of one kind or another because something
deeper inside of you takes you over and
performs through you.
It's not you,
but of course it is you.
So if you were going to come to me when
I was in the rock and roll business and
you want it to be my client,
I would give you a lecture.
I would say you have to understand
something.
If you are coming to me to fashion and
image to brand you and to make you a
superstar,
I'll get you an appointment immediately
within the hour with my best competitor.
Um,
but if you're going to work with me,
you have to understand that music is not
an exchange of pieces of plastic.
It is not an exchange of downloads.
It is not an exchange of money.
It's not about markets and branding and
all of that stuff.
Music is about an exchange of human
soul.
When you sit in front of a blank piece
of or two o'clock in the afternoon to
write a lyric,
you know you can never write a lyric
again cause you have no idea of how
you've ever written lyrics in the past
and at four o'clock in the afternoon,
very often there's a lyric there.
My job is to find the self inside you
who wrote that lyric and introduce it to
the self that says hello.
How are you?
Fine,
thank you very much and all the
ritualistic aspects of life.
When you go on stage you have the kind
of experience that I had.
You
are out of your own body,
your danced around as if you were a
marionette.
You feel a 17,000 souls coursing through
you to something higher being
transmogrified and channeling back to
those people and a continuous loop.
My job is to find that soul inside of
you,
the dances you on stage and introduce it
to the self of hello,
how you find.
Thank you very much.
So if you're willing to give me six
weeks to study you and then come out to
your environment and see you in your
environment for anywhere from one to
three days,
my job is secular shamanism.
Find that fucking soul that dances and
hang out with them.
I have not really hang out.
It would be a very intense interview
with John Mellencamp.
We started at nine o'clock in the
morning at his home in Seymour,
Indiana.
We finished at four o'clock in the
afternoon.
John,
look,
the way that he only looked when he came
off stage,
he looked hollowed out.
He looked like a scarecrow.
Um,
he had empty caverns where his eyes
should have been.
He was wiped.
He was totally wiped.
And that interview allowed me to find
the authentic John Mellencamp and preach
it to the press and turn depressed who
hated John Mellencamp around why they
hate him.
They hated him because he had signed
with Tony to freeze who was managing
David Bowie.
And Tony Jeffries thought that his magic
came from changing of people's names.
David had dave go a been named David
Jones and he changed it to Bowie.
And so he called John Johnny coover and
then he did something,
it sounds devilishly clever,
but was the opposite of clever.
He,
um,
had a book made with one page on each of
all of the dominant critics of the day.
One page,
a picture,
a little write up on each of them and
the press perceive this as trying to buy
them and they don't like being bought.
Um,
so they rebelled.
And the word went out in the press that
John Cougar was a Prek,
that he was just an obnoxious,
horrible human being and that his music
was crap.
And so even my friend can emerson,
my impression from Ken,
Ken was at that point,
the record reviews editor for rolling
stone and eventually he'd be an editor
at the New York Times Sunday magazine,
a very influential magazine nationwide.
And my impression was the Caen wrote his
review of John's album without ever
opening the shrink wrap without ever
listening to it because everybody was
assumed in that community that you knew
what John's music was crap.
And you know what,
his personality was crap.
And if you open the album and listen to
it,
you would be expelled.
People would shun you at the next
launch.
They wouldn't want you there or the next
Shinar even listened to it.
Yeah,
exactly.
You just,
you had to,
the group think had been established.
I'm pure pressure is tremendous within
the rock crit or was tremendous within
the rock critic.
Stablish um,
the rock among the rock critics and it
goes up so much power back then,
so crazy,
but they were so rigidly conformity and
forest.
Now this wasn't unique to the 1970
[inaudible] and 1980s because Carlisle,
the social commentator,
Thomas Carlyle and England and
approximately 1832 wrote about the pop
culture critics of his day and his day
pop culture was novels and plays and
how,
and he compared them to sheep.
And he explained how if you take a cane
and you put it out with the sheep
walking single file,
you can get 2000 sheep all walking in
single file.
And if you put your cane out in front of
lead sheep on the lead sheet,
jumped over your cane and then you
withdrew the cane.
Every one of the other 4,999 sheep would
jump at precisely the same spot even
though there was nothing to jump over
anymore.
Well,
that's how I perceived the rock crit
elite and my job was to turn them
around.
But my job was also to see true
ecstatics like prince,
like John Michael Jackson was not an
ecstatic onstage.
Michael Jackson wasn't incredible
astonishing performer who had studied
his craft from the age of nine.
And so he worked out every single move
and advance.
John,
you never knew from one night to the
next what prince or John Mellencamp
we're going to do in performance.
They didn't know how well did you know
Michael Jackson?
I thought very,
very well and he was the most remarkable
person I've ever met in my life.
And when I tell people how remarkable,
they don't believe me,
he was,
you know,
and I and Jamie are on a certain level
and we don't know we're on a certain
level because we figured these are the
range.
This is the range of humanity.
Um,
if we go out and meet anybody on the
street or even anybody famous,
I work with Buzz Aldrin these days,
what we're going to encounter is another
person pretty much like costs.
Sorry.
In Michael Jackson's case,
he did not fit on this normal plain at
all.
He was on a plane somewhere where you've
never seen a human being before.
So the first time I met him,
we were at his brother Marlin's
have pool house.
It's a little house with just enough
room for one big room on the first floor
and another big room on the second with
a little tiny staircase between them.
And there's a billiard table in the
middle of the room.
And there were arcade games,
which at that point in particular in
1983,
um,
were unattainable.
No human could afford arcade games.
Um,
unless you were Steve Wynn and you were
actually equipping in arcade.
Um,
so we're in the middle.
We're in this room and Michael and I are
standing next to each other,
so his elbow is at his left elbow is at
my right elbow.
His left knee is at my right knee and we
have a meeting with the art director
from CBS.
I'm condensing the story,
there's lots more,
but we're having a meeting with the art
director and she walks in with five of
the most gorgeous portfolios you've ever
seen in your life.
Hand carved cherry wood,
hand carved leather.
And these are from guys I know because I
was,
I started in pop culture in the art
business and these were my legendary
competitors.
And um,
and Michael opens the first page of the
first portfolio and he gets a square
inch into it,
a postage stamp size piece into it.
And he goes,
oh.
And his knees began to buckle and he
gets another two square inches into it
just lifts the page a little bit
further.
Oh,
he lifts it an even further.
Michael is seeing the infinite in the,
the things that even the artist didn't
see it with such infinity as Michael is
singing.
And by the time he gets to the full
page,
he's having a full scale aesthetic
orgasm.
I have never seen anything like this in
my life.
And remember,
the first two rules of science are the
truth at any price,
including the price of your life.
And look at things,
run under right under your nose as if
you've never seen them before.
And then proceed from there.
Michael is seeing the infinite in the
tiniest of things and you've never seen
a human with this degree of awe,
wonder,
and surprise anywhere in your life.
And I will never see another human like
that again in my lifetime.
Michael was beyond belief,
utterly beyond belief and his commitment
to his audience,
to his,
the people he called his kids.
Oh God,
I forgot to turn this off.
Uh,
have to call.
Um,
so let's find,
of course you're an android guy too.
Yes.
Uh,
Oh God.
How do we,
I know we pulled down from here.
I'm an incompetent with this stuff.
How could you be a people for people who
don't see you right now?
Because a lot of people are listening.
He has literally a Batman utility belt.
Um,
with two Kendall's you have to kindle
strapped to you at all times,
right?
You have the headphones for the podcast
and I have spare,
I have a total of three pair of
headphones on me because they were out
so quickly and they're going to need to
replace them.
Yeah.
What are you doing with them too?
No,
I'm petting dogs and that yanks them
around.
Uh,
the,
the best quality sound that I've been
able to get is in $8 headphones.
Well,
that doesn't make any sense.
It's extraordinary sound.
It's just that the wiring goes why,
why,
why is it the best quality sound?
Those cheap ass headphones.
It has the best quality base that I've
ever gotten worse.
Even though the ones that are like
straight wires with clear covers,
I'm going,
I actually get very annoyed when apple
got rid of the microphone.
Jack The headphone Jack on their phone.
While I would be annoyed too.
Yeah.
Because of that.
Such a high quality sounds.
Right.
So I'm surrounded with Electronica,
but when it comes to my phone,
my phone,
and I do not agree on what a command is.
So whenever,
well when I tried to pick up the phone
and answer it and hangs up when I'm not
trying to do anything on the phone,
it interprets that as a hand gesture of
some sort and does something.
Which one are you using?
The Samsung note eight.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
you know,
some people think that Samson's uh,
got a little bit of bloatware and their
songs.
Since you're an android guy,
have you ever considered using like a
google pixel two like,
well I like,
I like a big screen pixel,
two xl,
a six inch screens.
That would be very neat.
6.2 would be terrific.
It also,
when you squeeze the sides,
Google assistant pops up.
Yeah.
You squeeze the sides and he gets
started asking a question.
Well,
I need to find one that is also got the
headphone Jack on the top.
They don't have a headphone Jack.
Google got rid of the headphone Jack.
Oh my God.
No,
that's what I'm saying.
Because if you use,
if you use Bluetooth,
right,
if it's tuned to your cell phone,
you can't tune it to your kindle and you
can't tune it to your laptop.
And I need to be able to switch between
those three devices simultaneously.
Right.
So do you have that kindle fire hd
application where you can listen to it
and then as you're reading it,
it picks up back where you were
listening?
Well it does.
It's supposed to do that,
but sometimes it really wimps out and
takes me 30 pages a far away from where
I was reading.
And it becomes hard to find where I was
reading.
I mean,
you know,
this is why I curse jeff visas.
I hope he knows what he's doing in space
better than he knows what he's doing
with the kindle hdx.
Well,
I just don't think he could possibly
know all the things he's doing,
you know?
But you'll hire good people who do know
those things and,
and he's supposed to be cheap.
Like in terms of like how he pays
workers at the Amazon fact.
I would imagine that when it comes to
blue origin,
his rocket company,
that he is not cheap.
Oh,
I didn't even know he had a rocket
company.
He has a rocket company.
Elon Musk.
Yeah.
Look at you over these,
Jeff.
He thinks that he thinks that that space
x and Elon Musk are the hair and he's
the tortoise,
so he has launched a rocket,
the same rocket eight times now and
landed it again.
Really?
Yeah.
Same rocket.
The same rocket.
So he's demonstrated multiple reuse.
The problem is that his rocket can't,
you can only get to the fringes of
space.
It can't really get into orbital space
is right here.
Jamie just pulled it up.
You could look at it right there.
That's it.
Wow.
It's a real,
that's a real,
Jamie,
what does it look fake?
You haven't seen it before.
I don't know.
It doesn't look like Cgi U.
I sound like Eddie Bravo.
So it could be,
but he's actually launched this thing
eight times.
What's with the golf ball inside of
there?
I have no clue.
It's probably demonstrating that it,
that it's weightless.
Really extraordinary time of super
genius.
Dude,
incredible shit.
And this is how it lands.
It lands the same way.
That's exactly it.
Got It.
That's incredible.
And Elan says,
you know that Ellen has been landing his
rockets and he wants to read and he's
been reusing him.
I think he's done 11 reuses so far,
something like that.
But Elana sang that he's going to get so
precise in his landings that the rockets
will land precisely on the brackets from
which they took off.
Wow.
Yeah.
So,
and I was on the same pad.
I mean,
yeah,
it was a fairly small pad that the
Bayzos rocket,
so basis is a very well controlled
rocket Elan's you saw after the Falcon
heavy launch,
the pictures of the two boosters landing
simultaneously within a hundred yards of
each other.
You have to bring that up sometime
because it's an astonishing,
I like psychosis.
The Amazon prime videos they're putting
out there,
putting out some really great shows.
They're putting out a lot of standup
comedy now as well.
Right.
Which they're trying to somewhat compete
with Netflix.
And if you have a fair,
it is right there.
One of those heavy,
well that's,
that's it.
That's the money shot.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's critical for landing
simultaneous.
It's unbelievable.
So the goal here is up until now,
NASA,
which has been dumbed down so much,
it's ridiculous by Congress in the
Senate because Congress in the Senate or
insist on designing their own rockets
and ordered reus jobs programs not to
get us to space.
Um,
is that what the problem is?
It's is,
it's a funding issue too,
right?
It's like you have to have immediate
results for the amount of money that you
put the worse than that.
The,
there's a little thing called the
Alabama Mafia.
It's a bunch of senators and congress
from,
from Texas and Colorado and Ms
Mississippi and all of the states that
have rocket jobs and they have designed
a rocket called the space launch system
and it's going to cost $30 billion to
design it.
And it's a throwaway rocket.
So it's going to cost one to $2 billion
for each flight.
You think this is intentional?
Um,
it's intentionally,
yes.
It's intentionally stupid.
He thinks that,
yeah,
because it's designed for jobs and the
result is we Americans haven't had
access to space on American made
vehicles since 2011 that's a long time
now.
Um,
when we do get access to me and space is
going to come from Ilan mosque,
it's not going to come from any of the
major space
companies.
And $3 billion a year is sunk into the
space launch system.
This Turkey and another Turkey called
the Orion.
And that's money that needs,
we need that money to actually designed
the habitats on the moon design mining
equipment to mine the ice on the moon
and turn it into a rocket fuel and
breathable oxygen and drinkable water.
And there are tons of things we need,
but NASA is not producing them because
it's trying to compete with Elon and
Jeff,
Ilan and Jeff.
No,
he secret.
If I volunteered to fly you to New York
City,
and I told you I'm going to do this for
free,
I'm not going to charge you a penny.
All you have to pay or the expenses.
And then I bought you a Boeing seven 37
for $325,000 and allowed you and one
friend to get into this thing.
And then I flew you to New York and then
I flew the plane out into the Atlantic,
over the Atlantic and plowed it into the
Atlantic Ocean and discarded it.
Now when,
but I'm doing this all without charging
you anything you realize.
So when you want to fly back from New
York to California,
I'll buy you another seven 37 and other
$325,000 um,
and fly you back.
And then I'll fly the seven 37 out over
the Pacific and I,
we'll ditch it.
This is the way we do space it NASA
right now.
So how much would it cost you per ticket
for you and a friend to go from La to
New York and back again?
Approximately $325,000 per ticket.
How often would you fly from New York
to,
from La to New York?
Not very often,
if ever.
So that's what NASA is doing with the
space launch system.
And it's gobbling up so much money.
There's no funding left for the stuff we
really need to do.
Do you think it would be better if they
just privatized the entire venture?
It would be better if they offered word
called cots programs where you ask
companies to bid on getting a rocket
wherever you want it to go and doing
with that rock up whatever you want it
to do.
And then let Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos
and united launch alliance,
which is a big company underwritten by
the government,
that is a,
I can never remember the names of the
companies,
but it's Boeing and Lockheed Martin
combined and allow them all to bid on
this.
Um,
because Ilan is going to bring it in for
a 10th the cost.
Elon has developed the falcon heavy for
approximately $2 billion.
He's developed all of his rockets for
approximately $2 billion for all of
them.
It's costing NASA $30 billion to develop
a Turkey now.
Well,
how do they,
how do they keep doing that in the face
of these guys like Elon Musk and Jeff
Bezos,
congressmen and senators don't care.
They simply want to maintain the jobs in
their districts.
Plus,
if they feed the Smick,
the space military industrial complex,
the space military industrial complex
will kickback contributions to their
campaign funds.
Hmm.
As a result,
right.
So this is a,
an evil spiral.
I'm buzz Aldrin calls these,
the darth vader's of space for Lockheed
Martins and Northrop Grumman,
the big aerospace swoop,
traditional aerospace contractors.
So,
um,
it congressmen set a certain number.
It's a cabal of senators and Congressmen
who are screwing us up because a
country,
a country that dreams big gets big.
A country that looks up,
goes up,
a country that looks down,
goes down.
We've covered,
we become accustomed to looking down
because we don't have that glorious
option.
The moon is way behind us.
Um,
Baas and,
and Neil Armstrong walking on the moon,
that's a long time ago.
That's two generations,
two and a half generations ago.
And kids in America have lost that dream
of creating a paradise above the sky
because NASA is a mandan them and it's
mass has been forced to abandon them by
these congressmen and senators who steal
this money from the NASA budget.
But if that money were used,
look,
that $3 billion a year would mean that
you could develop an entire Elon musk
pace club program and launch roughly 20
rocket.
That is the issue.
The,
the actual engineers and the scientists
themselves,
I mean they must know it's politicians,
right?
But the politicians,
are they able to dictate what the actual
scientists and engineers create job?
Say,
Hey,
you must create something that is
disposable.
Yes.
Did they,
is that really a conversation that's
taken place?
He asked me,
guys have said,
okay,
we want to use um,
a space shuttle,
leftover space shuttle technology and
we,
and they,
they've mapped out the specifications of
the rocket that they want.
These guys are doing.
Yes,
that's right.
How's that possible?
Oh,
it's easy.
That seems disgusting.
They control the budget.
And one of the treks that the Smith,
the space military industrial complex is
known for a long time is you try to
parcel our jobs to as many states as
possible.
So major programs like the latest a
fighter,
um,
that the air force,
the navy are being told to use.
Um,
those represent jobs and roughly 45
states each.
That means that if your Lockheed Martin
and you want to keep your contract for a
plane that people are claiming can lose
to a 1951 era mig,
um,
all you have to do is hit the
congressmen and senators from those 47
states and they'll all back you.
Why?
Because they're counting on your
campaign contributions.
Where are you going to get the money to
give them a campaign contributions from
that billion to $3 billion nipple per
year,
that NASA has been forced to extend to
you or that the air force has been
forced to extend to you?
It's a very corrupt system.
That's a dirty system and it means that
the Russians and the Chinese can develop
equivalent aircraft for for one 10th the
price and deliver them for one 10th the
price would be mean.
You're totally talking about two super
geniuses,
Jeff Bezos and Elon Musk.
Imagine where it would be if they didn't
exist and exactly.
The odds are very high that they
wouldn't exist.
Uh,
the odds are very high that somebody
could do away with them.
It would be fairly easy.
Hey,
don't even put that out there.
Yeah.
Well the man on Friday or Sunday at the
National Space Society's annual event,
I'm talking about China's new Silk Road
versus America's highway in the sky.
The new Silk Road,
the Chinese government's going to put in
$1 trillion.
It's total of a $20 trillion project.
It pulls together something like 66
countries and 3.3 billion people.
And I co founded and chaired something
called the Asian Space Technology Summit
in Kuala Lumpur last May,
just about exactly a year ago.
And it was obvious being in Malaysia
that China has bought Malaysia's heart
that Americans don't count for much
anymore because the Chinese are already
spending money.
They already own 15 to 20 ports.
They own 15 to 20 ports puramus which is
the port of Athens,
the city that was the cradle of western
civilization.
Guess who owns it?
The Chinese and they are upgrading these
ports to do things that no port we've
ever seen before has been able to do so
because they have a big vision,
a really big vision.
They're going to dominate the 21st
century.
The 20th was the American Century.
This is going to be the Chinese century
unless we counter with an equally big
vision and the big visions are not
coming from Donald Trump in Washington
dc or from senators and congressmen.
They are coming from precisely the
people you fingered.
They're coming from Washington,
they're coming from California.
They're coming from Elon Musk and Jeff
Bezos,
the two guys who can save us by opening
a platinum highway in the sky.
What does that mean?
A platinum highway in the sky means the
space economy.
One meteor called something like a amen.
Three 35 has more resources than the
gross domestic product of England,
France,
Italy and South Korea combined in one
meteor.
Meteor I want,
I forgot to throw in India.
India is in that list too combined.
So it was the idea to minus mean you're
the last on it.
Yes,
exactly.
Another extract resources.
Yes,
bring them back.
But if NASA seriously wants us to
develop that space economy,
they have to do their part.
They have to,
Elan and jeff are bringing the rockets
to the table right now.
Reusable rockets like the seven 37 is
that we have now that we turn around in
La and send back to New York and then
turn around in New York and send back to
La for 35 to 40 years each.
They amortize their costs.
They allow you to get a round trip
ticket for as low as $220 on a really
good day.
Um,
um,
that's what's happening with space.
But where's the mining equipment going
to come from?
That's something NASA needs to be
working on.
Plus the mining equipment for the moon
to turn the moon basically into a fuel
station,
a rock.
I'm just thinking about this while also
thinking about all the other things you
think are,
because I do my best thinking when I'm
thinking about 15 things at once and
that's why the music is there because my
mind is empty if I don't have,
cause that's another threat going on at
the same time.
I want to bring you back to something
you said earlier that you sort of
glossed over,
but you were talking about quantum
physicists,
right?
Getting everything wrong.
So I told him so I flew to Moscow.
No,
and I've debunked that and a book called
the God problem.
How I godless cosmos creates that has
five heresies and Harrison.
Number one is that one,
is that a a does not equal a,
that's aristotle's primary law of
identity.
No,
it's not always true.
Um,
one of the laws is the theory of entropy
is so fucking wrong that it justifies
the entering means that all everything
is falling apart constantly.
And that in order to make something
positive happen,
you have to shed more negative energy,
not really negative energy,
more dispersed,
waste energy.
And in fact,
the universe doesn't look work like
that.
The universe in the very beginning at
form,
quarks from,
from nothing but motion quarks for
emotion.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah.
The first things from movement,
are you joshing?
No.
And then the quarks had to get together
in groups of three because this is a
profoundly social universal,
they couldn't survive.
And one form of Cork like this with one
up and two down or something like that
is a neutron.
And the other direction,
three quarks is a proton.
And all of this is anti entropic.
And then what do all of these billiard
balls do?
What are all these particles do?
[inaudible] hundred 80,000 years later,
they begin sweet themselves together in
these massive social agglomerations that
look like big potatoes.
And those are the beginnings of galaxies
before they form their spiral arms and
stuff like that.
Uh,
and then within the,
the spiral arms of these galaxies.
Gravity balls are competing with each
other to see who's the biggest gravity
ball and the biggest wins and what does
he do to the losers.
He swallows them and gets even bigger,
which makes it possible for that gravity
ball to confront another bunch of
gravity balls and beat them out for size
and swallow them.
Eventually.
What happens is you get so much gravity
and so much matter in this gravity ball
that the gravity ball explodes.
That's called a son a star and around it
are smaller gravity balls that managed
to hold their own in competitions and
their planets and moons.
How the hell do you go?
Even this short distance into the life
of galaxy that's been around for 13.7
billion years with precisely the
opposite of entropy happening.
What is the official definition of
venture be?
How's it defined by Webster's
dictionary?
Do you know?
It's usually a weasel definition weasel.
Yeah.
In other words,
it's deliberately obscure.
Ah,
because it's such a weird subject.
That's funny,
but every priesthood has a shibboleth.
A shibboleth is a magic word.
If you can't pronounce it,
you're dead.
Ah,
and so every tribe wants you to believe
in something that's impossible.
Remember the Red Queen or the White
Queen in Alice in Wonderland said,
sometimes I dream up six impossible
things before breakfast.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And you have to pass the test by showing
that you believe in something that's
obviously fatuously wrong.
And that's the the,
and the Shibboleth for being considered
a legitimate scientist is preaching
allegiance to pledging allegiance and
terpene.
Pull it up.
Let me see what it says here.
It says a measure of the unavailable
energy and a closed thermodynamic system
that is also usually considered to be a
measure of the systems disorder.
That is a property of the system state.
And that varies directly with any
reversible change in heat in the system
and inversely with the temperature of
the system broadly,
the degree of disorder or uncertainty in
the system.
So that's what they're saying is the
degree of disorder or uncertainty in the
system.
Now,
obviously that's a very lucid
explanation and you could recite it to a
five year old and need to understand
exactly what you were saying or to your
grandmother easily.
It is a little reason.
It's very weasley.
It has lots of outs.
So my book,
the God problem,
how a godless cosmos creates debunks
that along with a bunch of other
assumptions and current side is that
assumption exist?
He believes because in the 19th century
when this was formulated,
the metaphor of the day was the steam
engine.
It was the hot new technology.
It was to the the 19th century,
what computers are due the 22nd century
or whatever we're living in now,
the 21st century.
Sorry.
And um,
so what they realized was you take this
steam and you push it into a piston and
it throws that piston up into the air
and then the piston comes back down
again,
but then there's waste.
The steam then has lost its energy and
it comes out of an exhaust valve and you
put in more hot steam.
Right.
Um,
so this was a theory about the waste
that comes out of the steam engine.
But now that we don't have,
I mean cars,
yes they produce exhaust.
Now would you say that um,
solar power and solar power does not
produce exhaust.
So where's the entropy?
But where's the entropy?
Let's story of the universe.
I was telling you aggregation of the
batteries
cause I mean they are all
listening by on whatever that could be,
but it's a,
it's a square edge compared to the
construction of a sun.
Right?
It's a squid compared to the
construction of a galaxy and all that
random stuff in the universe.
All those random particles,
first of all,
they're not random.
They all participate in something.
The universe rings like a Gong and its
early days.
It has pressure waves.
That means that these elementary
particles are sketching together and
forming a wave.
Is that a technical term?
Yes.
And,
and then they're squinching apart and
they're forming a trough and then there
scorching together again and that wave
ripples across the cosmos.
The way that you see waves rippling
across the Pacific when you're flying to
Hawaii.
Um,
is that entropic,
is that disorder constantly increasing?
Now it's the very opposite.
What the universe does it,
it takes every form of waste and turns
it into an opportunity.
It,
I mean,
what we call this place earth,
what are we naming it for?
The Excreta of warms the shit of worms
because they produced what we call soil.
Well,
think of the meaning of that word.
Soil.
When something is soiled,
what does it like?
It's not covered with earthy loam.
It's dirty.
Um,
so,
and we call it dirt when it's in the
earth.
So we are taking this and tropic stuff,
the shit that came out of worms and
we're farming in it and plants are
growing in it.
Trees are growing in it.
Flowers are growing in it.
Is that entropy,
is that a continual slide toward
disorder?
It's the very opposite.
It's a continual slide toward order and
higher degrees of form.
How is this theory been received?
Um,
well,
uh,
or your interpretation of it?
That's a good question because,
um,
I really have no answer.
Um,
the people who I sent the book to in the
early days,
all of them except w well including a
Nobel prize winner.
And I think three macarthur genius award
winners all said this is a great book
and one compared it to Charles lyles
history of the earth,
which gave Darwin a lot of ideas and to
Darwin's origin of the species and
asked,
is this really a great book?
Like those two books?
And the answer has been yes.
And this is the Lucifer principle.
Oh,
this is the God problem.
How He godless cosmos creates.
And,
and let's not forget for the sake of the
audience,
we're actually here to promote how I
accidentally started the 60s.
The news is my newest book,
right?
It's my sixth book,
six.
But it was actually written during those
five years when I couldn't talk.
Wow.
Um,
the first draft was written during those
five years.
So there I was laying in bed not able to
talk.
And I know from all of my research that
when you are a human who feels of no
value to your fellow human beings,
you begin to die.
Your immune system goes into under
underperformance and stops protecting
you from diseases.
So I needed to somehow maintain a social
set of connections despite the fact that
I couldn't talk in my own wife,
couldn't walk into the room and read a
newspaper with me.
So what did I do?
I figured,
okay,
I'm most sick people churn,
churn out what are called repulsion
cues.
Cues that drive other people away.
They don't want to be near you when
you're sick and suffering and we really
don't kind as they may be.
Um,
so you have to put out attraction cues,
the opposite of repulsion cues and
what's an a number one attraction queue.
It's humor.
So there I was reading Dave Berry and
reading PG woodhouse and these guys were
lifting me for an hour or two above my
misery,
giving me this transcendent humor that
just took me out of my state at that
point.
So I tried to write transcendent humor
and I wrote this story of how I
accidentally help form a movement on the
west coast that had no name.
And then I left the country and when I
got back the loose empire,
the time life empire had given her the
name,
they called it the hippie movement.
And I tried to write her does.
Absolutely.
And it's funny,
a manner as possible.
And then when I was finished writing it,
I wrote because I couldn't talk,
I wrote a letter in those days they had
to be snail mailed because most people
didn't have email back then.
I did,
but most people didn't.
And I snail mailed my friend Eric
Gardner because Eric Gardner had started
out in the music business as a Roadie
for the Jefferson airplane.
And I wrote Eric and said,
Eric,
I just written this book,
could you get it to the Jefferson
airplane?
Cause if I could get them to say
something positive about that,
about it,
that validated it cause they were a key
act in the 1960s and Eric said,
no,
I have somebody better send me the
manuscript.
So I sent him the manuscript and he got
the manuscript to this other client of
his and the other client came back with
a quote that said,
it's a monumental masterpiece of
American literature and filled with,
while we want to have experiences and
nonstop waves of scientific comedy
routines and nonstop waves of hilarity
and compared to does James Joyce and
said,
wow woo and it and signed it.
Timothy leary and I thought this can't
be for real.
This just can't be for real.
But it was 1995 and what I didn't know,
it took me 15 years to find out is that
Timothy leary got this book when he was
sick in bed like I was,
he was dying of prostate cancer.
This book reached him six months before
he would die of prostate cancer and I
had written the book to be on a plane of
humor that would yank you out of your
body and Yank you up to an ethereal
plane of humor cause you were trying to
do that to yourself.
I needed to,
since these two guys had done it for me,
I needed to do my best to do it for
others and to attract people to stick
with me.
Cause I sent these things out,
his letters,
the chapters out,
his letters to friends,
hoping a few friends would still stick
with me.
And um,
when leary read it,
apparently it did for him.
What would house and Dave Barry had done
for me.
And I was stunned when I found that out.
Absolutely stoned.
So yes,
Virginia,
you can be in the worst of all possible
circumstances and you can pull together
something from low circumstances as a
gift,
your fellow humans.
And yes,
you will doubt that it will ever be a
value to any human on the planet because
that's what,
that's how us humans feel about most of
our endeavors.
Um,
bought some day.
It just may save somebody who's in a
position equivalent to yours.
That's amazing.
That is amazing.
What are the other things that the
quantum physicists got?
Ra?
Well.
Um,
all of them.
For four,
there was a four day conference,
um,
in a pouncing own of just outside
Moscow,
50 miles outside of Moscow.
It was a worker's paradise built in the
1960s.
And,
um,
and all the people there,
all the physicists were going around
drawing the same diagram on Napkins to
explain what they were talking about.
And it's a diagram of how short matures
equation manifest itself in one single
isolated electron.
Well,
guess what,
Jo,
there's no such thing as an isolated
electron in this universe.
There's no such thing as an,
uh,
an isolated Quanta of light.
And it's isolated photon of light.
There's no such thing as an isolated
anything.
I mean,
when you look up at the night sky,
what do you see stars,
some of those stars are 13 billion light
years away.
It's taken 13 billion years for that
light to get to us.
But we can still see those lights with a
telescope is if there is light flooding
the entire universe from low stars,
how could this be?
How could there ever be a particle
living on its own,
not awash in light,
gravitational effects,
electromagnetic effects from all the
other things in the universe,
or at least a good many of them.
So why is this,
was his misconception prevalent?
Uh,
it because the,
the equation fit certain very
artificial,
um,
experiments that were set up in the lab
and once an experiment has done and
accepted than everybody who doesn't get
the same results,
thinks he's doing it wrong and does it
over and over again till he gets the
same results and the explanation.
For some reason,
a lot of people in this universe think
we're on our own.
No,
we're never on our own.
We're always under the influence of
other human beings.
And look at the SARS.
Only the light is reaching us.
They're not determining,
uh,
whether you're rural friends going to
argue with you tomorrow,
like your horoscope says.
But there's that influence of merely
being able to see them.
So I was basically lecturing these guys
about a social cosmos in which
conversation,
information exchange is constantly
taking place all over the place.
And the,
and the fact that troubleshoots shirts
equation assumes an isolated entity and
there are no isolated entities,
these in this universe.
And when I was finished,
I expected them to throw me out of their
conference.
And instead they sat there as if this
had been my bar Mitzvah and I just done
a half tour or whatever it's called,
that you do what a bar Mitzvah.
And they were my uncles,
they were all sitting back,
their faces were beaming,
they were smiling,
you know,
that radiance,
that redness that infects a faceless,
excited about something.
It was astonishing and I couldn't
understand why.
And then three years later,
I have a collaborator in theoretical
physics,
Potlicker rock of the Kelly [inaudible]
suit of applied mathematics of the
Russian Academy of Sciences.
And Pavel emailed me and said,
doctor [inaudible] go off the man who
ran that conference,
the man who gave you such a hard time
about your credit card,
um,
he's just written a book.
You have to download it from arcserve
org,
which is the leading site for preprints
and advanced mathematics and advanced
theoretical physics in the world.
And so I downloaded it,
put it on my kindle and listened to the
first half while I was taking my
afternoon walk.
These long walks through the park can be
very helpful.
And when I got to the cafe where I was
working in those days and got my laptop
in front of me,
I wrote to doctor Rouger cough and I
said,
doctor Chekhov,
I don't know if you remember me,
I'm not crazy American who spoke at your
conference,
but I've just read the first half of
your book and it's phenomenal.
He used every concept that I had given
in my presentation,
every concept.
And I got one of those almost instant
emails back and email.
It comes within two or three hours and
who should go have said,
remember you,
didn't you read the first half of my
book?
And we are accredited in there.
My partner,
uh,
pavel and I,
so to at least a bunch of quantum
physicists from 11 times zones gathering
in Moscow.
Um,
what I was saying made sense quantum
physics.
Does it make sense to me?
Well,
I've tried.
Yeah,
I tried really hard.
It makes about the same senses.
That definition you were just reading
event trippy.
Exactly.
I'll go over it and over it again and
get little chunks of it and that would
understand like sections of sentences.
Right,
and then I'd have to try to put them
together with the other sections.
It's hard.
It's tough stuff,
but one of the most important things,
I think it was Neil's war who said this,
I'm not quite sure,
but one of the members of the Copenhagen
interpretation of quantum physics said
that basically a particle exists in many
states simultaneously and it's not until
it's measured that a collapses into one
stage.
That's one of the basic principles of
quantum physics.
Well,
guess what,
Niels,
every particle is being measured in some
way all the time,
all of its life by other particles that
are basically taking its measure and
then responding.
Essentially.
Nothing is isolated.
Nothing is isolated in this particular
cosmos.
You were talking,
I watched a video where you were talking
about that there is essentially a
universal brain.
Well,
yes,
because you and I right now we're going
to be talking to possibly out of your
500 words,
it's more like 1 million,
uh,
total viewers and listeners.
I'm more than that.
So it's probably closer to three.
Yeah.
So we're going to be talking to let's
say 100,000 of them or 200,000 of them.
Um,
and they're processing what we are
saying right now there are bacteria and
your gut and mine who live in enormous
colonies.
And An orb is bacterial colony.
If you had it on the palm of your hand,
it would be the size of your hand,
but you couldn't see it.
Are you thinking of this while you're
saying it,
are you thinking of that vast numbers of
people that are listening and watching
or are you just relaying the
information?
Like are you
cognizant?
Yup,
both.
Both.
Because I want,
remember Einstein gave me my marching
orders.
You have to take complex ideas and
simplify them so much that anyone with a
high school education and a reasonable
degree of on intelligence can understand
them.
And I want to make good radio for your
audience.
But once you,
what I'm trying to get at is once you
have got an established in your head
that nothing is isolated,
that everything is connected.
When you speak,
are you aware when you're speaking that
everything is connected?
I mean,
are you,
are you actually consciously thinking of
all of these different minds taking into
account all these different mind blowing
things that you're saying and then
applying them out in the world?
I think so.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
if you hear it coming out of my,
well that's what's churning around in my
brain.
I'm just,
you're,
you're such a bright guy.
I'm just trying to understand if you're
in the moment or if you're in the
moment,
as well as being consciously aware of
the spread of information.
My obligation is to do both
simultaneously,
simultaneous.
That's my obligation.
That's what I assumed.
Yeah.
So at any rate,
so the,
the entropic theory doesn't make any
sense.
The,
I mean,
look,
there,
I was in a bed,
right?
Right.
So you would think I'm totally isolated
and I'm not,
you're not.
I'm not.
I mean,
once upon a time I wrote an essay about
descartes.
Well,
descartes came up with the idea of,
I think therefore I am.
Um,
he took a retreat in Amsterdam.
He rented a second floor apartment and
he was trying to isolate himself the way
that those particles are isolated with
the short mushers equation,
the particles that were being drawn on
Napkins in Moscow.
Um,
and so that he could strip everything
away and find out what were the most
basic thing and the most basic axiom,
the most basic thing we take for granted
in life.
And he came up with,
I think therefore I am now.
Think about this for a minute.
While he was trying to think this out,
he was needing a rubbery gum eraser with
which he erased is inc he was sitting on
the second floor,
which means somebody had invented the
architecture that he was sitting in and
the concept of the floor and the concept
of beams that go across from one wall to
the other
that were holding him up.
He was looking out the window and he was
looking at the hats that the Amsterdam
men and women were wearing as they
walked by and he was fucking in the
cleaning lady whom he made pregnant.
So how isolated really was he
the universal mind theory this or this
concept?
It shouldn't say theory.
Um,
w the way you were describing it,
it's very interesting that there is no
individual thought that essentially
there's,
there's lots of individual thought.
It's all connected,
right?
To all the other people that are around
you and all the people that you've
interacted with and all the places
you've been and the things you've seen
and all the people that are constantly
thinking simultaneously around you that
you're aware of
and the people that you're trying to
influence because you're trying to
influence people all day long.
Right?
Um,
if you want somebody to bring you a
sandwich,
you have to get across that.
You want that sandwich.
And especially if you want somebody like
a wife or an assistant to bring you a
sandwich and that's not normally what
they do,
then you really have to work hard and
influence going.
But,
but the the universe,
at least the living part of the universe
and so far we only know of life on this
planet.
It's all interconnected.
Those bacteria I was talking about there
in your gut,
they are making your vitamin B.
They are making your vitamin K,
they are making an awful lot of the
things that you use to survive.
They're also making chemicals that
influence your mind and your moods.
They're manipulating you.
So when you go down to the corner store
to buy some chocolate,
a claire's and you go home and you eat
them.
In fact,
you can only digest a small portion of
the chocolate,
a claire,
those bacterial colonies living in your
gut.
They do the rest of that I adjusting for
you.
So who's really going to the corner
store?
Who's really the boss who's really
driving you the vehicle of
transportation?
Are these bacteria driving you down to
the corner store so that you will feed
them the stuff that they love the most
or ours your will driving you to the
corner store?
While the answer's a little of both,
a little of both.
Not as much of both.
I mean there,
there's this example of
there's this fungus and the fungus has a
very peculiar lifestyle and I'm very
curious to find out how it got this
lifestyle.
But it lives half of its life in an ant
colony and half of its life and a sheep.
So when it comes out of the phase of
that,
it goes through in the ant colony and is
ready to go into the sheep,
it takes over the brain of an ant and it
gets that ant to climb to the top of a
stalk of grass.
Why?
Because when the sheep come along to
graze,
they will inhale the ant.
What you're telling me that a fungus can
control the mind of an ant and ways that
we're just beginning to explore now this
year and maybe last year a tiny little
bit,
that it can actually be that precise in
how it takes over the controls of that
to one of those,
uh,
the fungus that gets inside those ants
and the ants are aware of it.
So they take the ant away because the
aunt will explode and spray spores into
the air and it will affect the,
in fact I'm not aware of that one,
but it sounds cordyceps.
Yeah,
but it sounds similar but the real deal
is,
okay,
life on this earth functions the way
that a beehive functions and how does it
be high functioning?
95% of the bees are conformist peas and
they out go out to the hot flower patch
of the day and they mine the nectar and
they have a public stomach in which they
can carry this stuff.
I mean built into them inside of them
and they have these carrying Harris on
their thighs and they carry pollen in
those and when they arrive at the
unloading bay,
there is an unloading bay and the hive
and when they arrive at the unloading
bay,
if the unloaders no,
that the interior really needs pollen
and nectar and they see you carrying
that pollen and nectar,
they stick their tongues down your
throat to check out what's in your
public stomach.
They go wild with excitement.
When they discover it's filled with
nectar,
they check out your thighs,
the caring hairs on your thighs.
They go wild.
When they see that you're carrying pond,
they feel you all over with their
antenna.
They are intensely excited when they are
unloading you and that gets you excited.
You feel like a rockstar because this is
the same kind of attention a rockstar
gets.
So you go back out to the flower patch
of the day and mine some more.
Meanwhile,
there are these lazy good for nothing.
Bohemian bees,
there are anywhere from 5% to 20% of the
colony and they don't do a single useful
thing at all.
And so far as you can see,
they don't do anything to earn their
keep in the colony.
Why?
Because they're out doing loop after
loop after loop and lazy eights after
lazy aids,
after lazy aids,
they'll fly eight miles just following
their whims,
following their whims.
I mean if you were their mother,
what would you say?
You're wasting your fucking life for God
sakes.
Okay?
Eventually you the conformance be star
coming back without pollen and you're
carrying Harris and without nectar and
your public stomach because the flower
patch,
that flower patches of the day has been
thoroughly plundered.
And when you arrive at the unloading
dock of the hive,
the unloading be stick their tongue into
your public stomach empty,
sorry.
They see are carrying Harris empty.
They turn their backs on you so savagely
that you feel as if you've been cut dead
and it finally,
I mean you can't believe that the old
factories not delivering anymore and
it's not giving you a paycheck.
So you keep going back to the same patch
over and over again more slowly each
time until finally you give up and you
literally crawl into the hive.
And Thomas Sealy,
the guy who's done most of the research
on this,
calls you on unemployed b and you are as
depressed as if you were an employee.
How do we know that?
Because your body temperature is down
and you're crawling instead of walking
and you're begging for food from other
bees.
Well,
you look for something to perk you up.
Now,
what do humans use a football game?
A movie bees use pretty much the same
thing.
What does that mean?
They go to the unloading dock out of the
200 lazy good for nothing.
Bohemian be simply following their
instincts.
Five have come back having found new
flower patches and they are dancing and
the dancing excites you and they're
dancing in competition with each other.
Some will dance 27 seconds,
some will dance 27 minutes.
And if you find the dance of one of
those dancers sufficiently persuasive,
it lifts you out of your lethargy,
gets you excited and you fly out.
She's giving a little in a little figure
eight dance.
She is giving precise instructions on
how to get to the flower patch and what
the headwinds are and what the tail
winds are.
And you pick up her message,
you fly out to the flower patch to that
she has recommended and you check it out
for yourself.
And if you get excited about it,
you come back and you start dancing.
And ultimately the be who gets the
greatest number of backup dancers wins
and you all go out,
all you can form us.
Bees were now unemployed.
Go out to the new hot flower patch of
the day in the same pattern repeats
itself.
Now that's a collective mind operating
on the basis of 20,000 independent bees
and the the living world operates and
pretty much the same way bacteria are
using you to get them chocolate eclairs.
You are using them to digest chocolate,
a eclairs.
They are teasing our scientists and to
wild activity by threatening to develop
illnesses that can bypass all of our
antibiotics,
which by the way are chemical weapons
that microorganisms,
colonies of microorganisms,
organisms use to kill entire competing
colonies.
We stole him from microorganisms,
so we didn't admit them antibiotics.
So the scientists are very worth fact
that the bees are,
that the bacteria are getting ahead of
us in research and development and are
beginning to develop techniques to get
around all of our drugs.
So they are researching their ass off.
So is there any common brain that links
the bacteria to the scientific
community?
You bet they're competing with each
other and in the process of competing
with each other,
what are they doing?
They are both creating new options for
all of life.
Wow.
So when we're talking about antibiotics,
penicillin or amoxicillin and stuff like
that,
these are bacteria created
Korean boys,
bacteria make war with each other.
When people tell you we are the only
creatures that make war,
they're allying.
So is this why also when,
especially if you're experimenting with
your,
um,
people that have a,
a very sugar based diet,
they have a high number of certain kinds
of bacteria in their stomach that craves
that kind of sugar and it makes it very
difficult to get off that,
that kind of a diet.
Well,
that's interesting.
I mean,
I'm not aware of that,
but it sounds,
it sounds logical given gut bacteria
about the biome.
Yeah.
When you find out,
uh,
one of the things,
if you try to alter your diet,
if you're in a very high refined
carbohydrate diet and you try to get off
of that,
the,
you have intense cravings,
but those eventually go away.
Especially when you supplement with a
lot of probiotics and then you'd go to a
high fat,
low carbohydrate diet,
you start to crave those kinds of foods
and the cravings for sugar and bread go
away.
It's very strange.
Well,
that's interesting because I am on a
very restricted diet myself.
I developed it myself.
It's take,
it took 30 years down.
It's a diet that maximizes my energy and
my ability to concentrate.
What's a tangle meal?
Uh,
there are only two meals.
Um,
breakfast is a can of tuna fish and
avocado and mango.
Um,
that's at 10 30 in the morning,
um,
dinner,
which is at three o'clock or two 30 in
the morning,
two 30 in the morning.
Yeah.
Remember I'm an odd schedule that I'm
primarily nocturnal because of my
illness,
right?
So dinner is a half a pound of ground
chicken,
a pound of frozen vegetables and apple,
an orange and a banana.
Why frozen vegetables?
Because you can get them in one pound
bags,
so it's precisely premeasured for you.
Um,
and they freeze them when they're fresh
and you can throw them along with a slab
of,
um,
chopped chicken.
Um,
frozen slab,
uh,
into a microwaveable container and
microwave them for 15 minutes.
I mean,
throw a lot of spices in so that you
change the flavor,
but a day after day and you've got
dinner and that's all you ever eat.
That's all I ever had except,
uh,
on Friday I allow myself to eat sauces
and cheese sauces out of a jar because I
don't eat things that have artificial
ingredients or additives of any kind
normally.
And so I have this wanking huge meal and
then on Saturday alr and myself to
splurge on absolutely anything I want to
eat.
So that's your cheat day?
Yeah.
What do you find yourself going to on a
cheat day?
Well,
these days I've sort of settled into a
pattern and I take one frozen bag,
all a big one out of the refrigerator.
I slice it in half.
I put huge amounts of peanut butter on
one hand when he first,
I use a quarter of a pound of butter and
I slather on the two halves of the
Bagel.
Uh,
cause I'm not allowed to eat any of
these things.
Bread not allowed to eat butter?
No.
Why is that?
Well we're told that butter is bad for
us and it and dairy turned out to be a
problem for me and I had a workout,
I had to work away around my food
allergies and this is the Diet
[inaudible] allergy to dairy.
I apparently did.
I'm not sure I still do but so these
huge honking amounts of butter and then
I take these giant slabs of peanut
butter and I pile them up with a leaving
a little hole in the center and in the
hole in the center I put grape jam and
strawberry jam and then I take out the
marshmallow fluff and I put on almost an
entire jar of marshmallow fluff on top
of this one,
half a bangle cause I really want to
taste the bagel naked with just butter
on it because I haven't had bread all
week and it can taste really good and I
am indulging myself with this other half
of the Bagel.
How bad do you feel after you digest
that?
I don't feel bad.
I said,
I eat before I go to sleep and well,
eating puts you to sleep.
Why should you have to slog through the
gray goo of your after meal experience
with,
with your friends?
I mean,
I,
if I'm with a friend,
I want to be at my maximum.
Um,
I want to enjoy then how do I enjoy
myself with my mouth open and my tongue
going?
Right.
So even having food in your mouth,
it's just preventing you from having a
good coffee.
Wow.
That's a fascinating way to approach it.
So you just will also,
if you carb up like that,
you know,
with all that sugar and carbs,
you're going to want to crash in about
40 minutes after you,
and that turns out to be the case
anyway.
So I sleep immediately after my
breakfast and then I sleep immediately
after my dinner.
And that's the way the day is a range.
It's a range to maximize the useful high
energy,
high focus time.
Now did they ever try to put you on any
kind of unfettered means or anything?
Um,
no,
not really.
Um,
and,
and my experience,
you know,
I helped start the 60s.
So,
um,
I helped start the drug culture and that
meant I did amphetamine twice.
It was brand new back then and whatever
form it was popular
provigil or Nuvigil.
I have a friend who has chronic fatigue
and that's where they put him on.
Well,
the stuff,
I'm on work so well,
I don't want to mess with it at this
point.
I'm lucky to be out of that bad.
I thought I would.
I Joe,
I thought I would never be out of that
bedroom again in my life.
And you've been out of the bed for 15
years.
Yeah.
That's 15 years.
That's amazing.
Right?
So I'm giving three speeches this week
at the
18 and 15 out.
Yeah.
Right.
Yup.
So,
um,
you have so much energy.
It's hard to imagine you being
bedridden.
I mean,
it really is your,
your,
I couldn't form a single syllable.
I mean,
I believe you.
Yeah,
I do believe you,
but I'm just saying it.
Seeing you in this state,
you're smiling,
you're,
and obviously what you said about
enjoying conversations and it's so
parent.
He really enjoy getting these ideas
across.
Well,
this is
tremendous.
I mean,
I,
I'm still dealing with how to get across
the idea of a global brain,
but it's basically every creature on the
face of the earth.
This in some way contributing to our
knowledge base and our hunter gatherer
days.
If we were going to bring down a d or an
eat it for dinner,
we had to get to know the mentality of
that deer.
We had to be able to shape it in our own
minds so we can anticipate its
movements.
So we anticipated the movements of
lions.
We anticipated the movements of eagles.
We turned lions and Eagles and bears and
to totems and named ourselves after them
because we were trying to learn from
their very spirit.
We were trying to learn muscularly and
emotionally how to be them so that we
could defeat them.
When the time came.
There's a connection there.
There's a global brain taking place
right there,
and the deer and the block and the Bison
and the other creatures we were hunting.
Even the wooly mammoths could not have
lived without those bacteria in their
guts.
Now,
we didn't discover those bacteria and
tell Anton van Leeuwenhoek dare to take
his lens and instead of having it
horizontal to measure fabrics or we're
looking at fabrics,
started looking down at his own sperm,
which was a very,
I mean,
look at what this guy did.
He's a tradesman.
He's not a trained scientist.
Of course,
the word scientist didn't exist until
eight roughly 1850 but nonetheless,
he is taking his observations of fresh
human sperm through his newly invented
microscope and he's sending the
observations.
He's discovered that there are
animalcules little animals,
totally independent,
flailing around in this farm and he
writes a lengthy letter about this to
the royal society.
Now what has he just John Joe to the
Royal Society.
He's confessed to masturbation.
Oh my God.
Where do you think he got the sperm?
I mean,
it took me about 40 years of thinking
about,
it may be 50 to work it out and then I
suddenly realized this guy is,
why does masturbation keep showing up in
my life?
One look,
the boy scouts threw me out when I was
11 years old for incompetence at Morse
code.
And if they hadn't thrown me out for
incompetence of that,
they could have thrown me out for
incompetence at knot tying.
Now admittedly I've never heard of
another human being ever being thrown
out of the boy scouts,
but still then in my thrown out of the
boys.
That's right.
For a long time code and sit Morse code
being competent at Morse code.
Yes.
It seems so simple
to me it wasn't simple.
So at any rate,
I mean I was too busy with theoretical
physics and cosmology.
You just uninterested.
Yeah.
It wasn't that you were in competent,
you really never bothered to learn it
was to,
I had other better things to do.
Something better than Morse code before
that.
Right.
So at any rate then in the,
in the summer between my freshman and
Sophomore Year of college,
I mean,
I dropped out for three or so.
I was going to back to freshman year at
the age of 21.
Why'd you drop out?
Well,
I wanted to find the beatniks.
I wanted to find zen Buddhist Satori,
the Zen Buddha state of enlightenment.
I was dead serious about those things.
I was in the top 10% of a class that had
higher meeting sats than the classes at
Harvard,
Mit,
and Caltech.
That year.
It was at Reed College.
The school that Steve Jobs would
eventually drop out of very tough
school.
And I didn't realize I was in the top
10%.
But nonetheless,
I had these things I wanted to do.
I was inspired by on the road.
I felt the beatniks are the first people
who would ever accept me and my life.
Um,
you were reliving the time you were
carried away by the children.
Yeah.
Well,
so,
so I,
I drop out of school and went seeking
Satori and the beatniks and hitchhiked
from Seattle down to,
um,
the city lights bookstore op,
which was Lawrence Ferlinghetti is
bookshop.
And that's where the beatniks yeah,
that's,
uh,
that's where the beatniks are supposed
to be hanging out.
And I walked into the store and it was
empty and there was a guy behind the
counter and I probably said something
like,
uh,
where are the beatniks?
And he acted as if I wasn't even there.
Now that was hard,
Joe,
because I had a Jew for over kind.
People have been wearing their short,
their hair,
their haircuts and military haircuts,
crew cuts.
And I had this long curly hair and no
one had ever seen anything like it
before.
The closest to it was the wig that Harpo
Marx used to wear wasn't,
that wasn't the,
some of the members of the experience.
They get you there.
There's a photo of you.
What does that photo from?
Probably 1965,
1966.
That is a patient and the guy who so,
so how could you ignore if that walked
into your bookstore and you'd never seen
a haircut like that before and the
person was barefoot in addition to that
and carrying a sleeping bag,
you were barefoot with a sense.
I had been barefoot for six months and
your feet get so thick that you go walk
over gravel.
I will ask,
why are you barefoot for six months?
It felt like the right thing to do under
the circumstances or the swelling?
No.
Eventually I gave it up.
Do you have any houses left?
No.
No,
no.
I can't walk over gravel anymore.
Long for those days where you can do no,
I like current shoes.
I love her and choose.
So at any rate,
but it would,
you ignore what you just saw that person
with hair coming out of his head,
like electrocuted worms.
Love.
I'd be like,
this guy has got something to say.
What's up?
Yeah,
the guy ignored me.
So I walked out of the bookstore looking
crushed and somebody walking down the
sidewalk said,
you look troubled.
Can I help you with something?
And I said,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm looking for the beatniks.
And he said,
well,
and he rolled his pupils up into his
forehead and he scratched his head and
he thought,
and he thought,
and then he came out of it and he said,
well,
have you tried Colorado?
Well that was just a little too vague.
A destination for Colorado.
Yeah.
With a beat.
Nixon,
Colorado.
I have no idea.
He thought they might be.
Yeah.
So I ended up hitchhiking up and down
the west coast with several friends gave
up.
You gave up on the beatniks.
We gave up on the beatniks because I
wasn't a specific address and I didn't
want to leave.
What year is the West Coast?
It was 1962.
Uh,
you were early.
It was two years before the sixties woke
up and realized that it was a distinct
decade.
It was two years before the electric
koolaid acid test and hung around a
little bit.
You would have been their perfect,
well,
I prefer starting my own groups
actually.
And this group gathered around me and
around on one of my traveling
companions.
And we eventually ended up in a big pink
condemned house.
This is all in how I accidentally
started in the 60s and a big pink
condemned house in Berkeley,
three blocks away from the Berkeley
campus.
And we didn't care if it was going to
fall down at any minute.
Um,
and we,
we were no close zero clothing during
the day.
And My,
I guess co leader was a guy named Dick
[inaudible] who had the body of an
autonomous when we walked down the
street together,
women could not take their eyes off of
him and,
but they slice through me as if I were
weren't there is if I were invisible and
every woman wanted to sleep with him.
Um,
and he had this sense of somehow he had
lived a life up to that point with never
having a depression,
never having a doubt,
never having a psychic pain of any kind.
It was uncanny,
was unreal.
And,
and remember Michael Jackson is still
the most remarkable person I've ever
met,
but to cough was pretty remarkable.
And so dick set the tone being naked and
Dick would go into the bathroom to do
the things you do in the bathroom,
but leave the door open and continuous
conversation with you while he was in
there going.
So that was the norm for us.
And I was the spiritual leader of the
group.
So at the time I was 19 or 18 years old.
So I like to be a spiritual leader at 19
it feels very good when people believe
in the things that you say.
It feels very good when you're
hitchhiking and somebody takes you to
macarthur park in La and there are all
these guys on soapboxes and or aiding
their heads off about Marxism or the
coming of Jesus or whatever.
And somebody in the crowd while you're
just watching what's going on,
walks up to you and says,
you look like the idiot and the Dusky
asking novel.
So he doesn't mean that as a,
you look like an idiot.
He's talking about something unusual.
And,
and I start explaining to him what I'm
doing.
And before long,
all of the crowds around,
all the guys on soap boxes with all of
the Marxist and Jesus lectures have
abandoned their speakers and they're all
listening to me.
Well,
you can tell I really get off.
I'm talking to an audience of anywhere
from one person to 100,000 people,
whatever.
I don't care.
It lights me up and so did it feel good?
Yes.
So you feel like that doing that as
you're calling?
Yes.
Yeah.
That that's what I'm here for,
but I'm here to write the books to now
writing the books is a lonely
proposition.
Writing is very lonely.
You have to isolate
yourself.
That's why I do it at a coffee shop.
We're out of the corner of my eye can
see humans around me and where I can
spend four hours in and be profoundly
rude.
Because when you're in the middle of
balancing seven ideas and you're
fashioning a sentence,
if somebody interrupts you for half a
second,
right?
All those things can go crashing and
disappear.
I,
I don't understand the need to do it in
front of all these people because I need
the energy of other people with a lot of
people that live in New York City.
My friend Jeff said that he wouldn't
live anywhere else.
He loves New York City because he gets
energy out all the people that live
there.
And I can't,
I mean,
I've tried Seattle,
Portland,
San Francisco,
San Pedro,
and the only does it for you.
Oh yes.
In ways I never imagined.
I never thought,
how long did it take before you realized
that that was the spot for you?
Not that long.
Because what I realized about seven
months into it was I don't fit into
clique's clique's don't want me and I'm
not comfortable.
Well,
I'm generally not lotted in clique's.
Oh,
you'd be whining.
I don't really have one.
But
that's very sweet.
That's very nice.
But so at any rate,
I discovered that in New York there are
so many people that you can pick people
one by one and put them together into
your own clique.
And if you put them together in your own
clique,
you always maintain a certain central
role,
even if you would,
the people that are in the clique and
you really want to advance them it,
you're still accepted.
I um,
I'm around giant groups of people.
So,
so often because of the UFC doing
commentary and in these huge arenas,
Philippine wow.
And then doing standup in front of
thousands of bees and then the podcast
reaching all these people I need alone
time.
Like I have the opposite requirement.
I need that.
If I don't get like my writing,
I have to write a loan.
I right when everyone's asleep,
right house.
I wait until everyone goes to bed and
then I do my writing and I've learned,
I guess it's a discipline.
Yeah.
How would it be alone in the midst of a
lot of people?
Right.
And you need the energy,
the energy.
So what I want you to describe to me,
he's like,
what is the energy of these people
around you?
Like what is happening?
First you have to understand it's not a
distraction.
No.
We are built to take in input from other
human beings and to give output to other
human beings.
And when we feel unnecessary,
as I sat,
her immune system goes into under dive
nose dive and so we need to be around
other people.
Now if you're a writer and you write and
I write as you said,
you need to isolate yourself.
So I've figured out a way to be utterly
isolated in the midst of a bunch of
people.
I need the energy from those people
because otherwise I do my best writing
when I'm feeling the energy of my
audience.
But if you don't,
you you do.
When you do get interrupted,
I should say it does fuck you up.
You have,
so I simply writing,
I'm just saying writing.
Oh Wow.
But I do it without ever lifting my eyes
from the page.
I've learned to discipline my mind.
Something like that.
Fuck you manage one and a cigarette.
Yeah,
but they,
they know me all.
They know I'm sure to the mayor of the
chocolate area,
the cafe where I work.
Don't give the name out man.
Well,
I'm respected there and a lot of Weirdos
out there and when that spot that could
be,
but yeah,
so but don't get about the address,
but we need,
you know,
we need social input.
We desperately need it.
So as you said,
you can only be alone after too much
social input.
Yes.
Now I do a show called coast to coast.
It's a crazy weird flying saucer show.
Yeah,
it's the highest rated overnight talk
radio show in northeast Georgia.
Nori is still the host and it's 545
radio stations and they'll one night
that,
I mean they'll call me on no notice and
say we need you on tonight about the
neurovirus we need you on tonight about
the killing in Texas,
the school shooting in Texas.
We need you on tonight about the Gaza
riots and Israel and you just jump on
and talk about it.
I like to get five hours,
six hours notice because I like to put
in three hours of research and bought
one night.
I was walking out in the middle of that
meadow in the park looking at the stars
and my phone be answering now 1140 at
night or 1240 at night.
When you're commuting with the stars,
you don't really want to answer the
phone.
But I'm on call for coast to coast.
I thought always on call.
Yes,
I've done it 237 times.
That's crazy.
And they call me the human computer.
So cause they can ask me questions about
anything.
Did you do it during the art bell days
as well?
Yes,
but art would have me on for four to
five hours and that was a hoot.
That was really a hoot.
I did his show once.
It was a highlight of my life.
Well art was one of the most energetic
talk show host you've ever seen in your
life.
Have that guy.
So he would call at four in the
afternoon and he'd say,
okay,
I want you to look at this website.
So I go look at the website and call me
when you look at it.
So I'd call him again and he said,
okay,
now look at this website now.
Gradually I got the idea that he was
trying to tell me that there were extra
galactic civilizations and that they
were coming to earth and signaling us
through crop circles and a whole bunch
of other things.
But it was the way he did it.
He did it with such energy.
He lit a fire in you.
Absolutely.
Even if you totally disagreed with
everything he was thinking,
he lit that fire.
I used to drive home from the comedy
store at night,
and it was the only,
one of the only things that I would
listen to because it was am radio,
and I would get it from a,
believe it was a San Diego station and
you could usually get it better late at
night.
Right?
So it'd be like one o'clock in the
morning.
I was driving into the valley and I'd be
listening to the coast to coast with art
bell.
Right.
And a lot of people that came to have,
not a lot of people did that.
A lot of,
a lot of intellectuals do that as their
secret sin and because they're awake
late at night and there's nothing
else really on the radio and this at
least teases a little bit of your brain.
So I do global,
I do global history,
I do global geopolitics.
I do a geoeconomics.
Um,
I do psychology,
I do murders,
I do bacteria.
I do stars do your own show while I was
at the guy who created the show with art
bell who created coast to coast with art
bell,
um,
he wanted to do a radio show where I can
have as many nights of the week as I
wanted.
And the guy who wrote conversations with
God would have the other nights.
Why don't you just do a podcast?
I do,
uh,
not,
not a podcast.
I do a youtube.
Oh,
okay.
Thing.
Why don't you put it out as a podcast as
well.
You can just take the audio from it.
Well,
I have very little time in which to do
this,
so I know how to put it up on youtube
and it doesn't get that many hits.
I mean,
I used to do Tj Kincaid,
the show with him,
the amazing atheist.
He's,
well,
he's fabulous and six foot eight or
something like that.
He's a good dude.
I like that.
Oh,
I like him too.
And so he had me on for two years
running and then said,
you've got to start your own.
So I started up my own and he of course
at this point has 950,000 subscribers or
something like that.
I have 13,400 subscribers.
Try to pump you up.
That will be neat.
That would be terrific.
You really should do your own thing.
It's not difficult to do.
Right.
And once it gets set up,
uh,
it's fairly easy.
Recorder.
We'd have to set me up out.
Meantime,
I said,
but look at me.
I'm I buzz Aldrin said 12 years ago.
We've got a presidential election coming
up and we've got to try to get space on
the agenda of the things that candidates
are talking about.
We've got two years in which to do it.
And I said,
okay,
I'll form a group to do that.
So do this.
Let me ask you this,
because you're this big coast to coast
Art Bell Fan,
right?
How much of that Ufo stuff do you pay
attention to?
None.
Zero.
When when people contact me on Linkedin
and their major credential as they do us
a Ufo magazine or something like that,
I don't add them.
I used to love that stuff.
I think it was so interesting and
intriguing.
Tell us I started actually paying
attention to it.
Yeah.
And I started interviewing some of the
people that involved in the movement.
You find the same thing over and over
again.
This just wanton disregard for reality
is absolute desire to prove something
instead of looking at the objective
facts that proving that aliens are real,
proving that we've been contacted these
eye witness testimonies are legitimate.
Let me try to get across a weird idea.
Okay.
Um,
once upon a time in the 1940s,
there were two guys,
Connor Lorenza,
Niko Tinbergen,
who got a Nobel prize for inventing a
field called pathology,
which is a certain kind of observation
of animal behavior.
And Niko Tinbergen will go off to the
coastal cliffs around northern Europe
and he would observe
the seabirds and the seabirds will go
out,
I don't know how many miles,
10 30 40 miles and outs of the ocean to
feed and bring back food for their
young.
And then they would come back at the end
of the day and their desks,
they'd have 200 nests next to each
other,
but the ness had very low walls.
So when the seabird came back from her
fishing and waddled herself into place,
moving her hind back and forth to get in
place to incubator chicks to warm the
eggs,
she'd often knock an egg out.
And when the egg was knocked out of the
nest,
the bird would reach her beak out past
the egg and then pull her beak back in
towards your chest to pull the egg
toward the nest.
And she do it over and over again until
she got the egg in the nest.
And Niko Tinbergen have this word idea.
I wish I knew where it came from that
this is a reflux.
You know,
like when your doctor takes a hammer and
hammers your knee and your,
your black shoots out and you had
nothing to do with it.
He figured this is the same kind of a
reflex and he figured that if you have a
reflex you need a trigger for the
reflex.
Like that Patellar Hammer,
that hammer journey.
So he looked to see if there was a
trigger that triggered this yanking your
beat back on in order to scoop the ag
back into the nest.
And he tried building artificial eggs to
see if he could find out what the cues
were in the ag that were causing this
reaction in the word.
And finally he got a super vague,
which means I knew it was bigger than
the normal ag.
It was browner than the normal ag and
he'd put the real egg.
Now if you're the bird,
that real egg has your genetic legacy.
It's your genetic future.
A lot is riding on that egg.
A lot of you and the phony egg and the
phony ag would attract the bird so
strongly that she would ignore her own
egg and Yank,
Yank,
Yank.
With her beak until she pulled the phony
egg into the nest and they continued to
do research with this kind of thing.
And they discovered that they could
trick some songbirds into taking a
basketball into their nest.
And then when the poor little birds
tried to get on top of the basketball to
incubate it,
they would slide off and they'd be very
frustrated and they would climb back on
again and slide off again.
It was cruel.
So the phony eggs like fake tits,
those are things called supernormal
stimuli.
And the idea is that they bring these
reflexive reactions.
Yes.
Well underlying what Adolf Hitler was
doing underlying what I was doing,
dancing on that stage,
um,
underlying what you do in front of an
audience when you get incandescents and
lose yourself and something else talks
through you.
Um,
all that is related to some super normal
pattern in us.
So Hitler was basically saying the world
is about to end and the Kingdom of God
is coming except the Kingdom of God in
his case was the world will be
controlled by the master race,
the blonde and blue eyed ariens.
And all other people will be slave
people or will be exterminated.
Um,
but it was this golden paradise that he
was inviting the Germans too,
in which they ruled the world because
they were born to rule the world.
So how did you describe the stimulation?
Super supernormal stimulus.
So the silver tsunami,
still a stimulus of this artificial egg
is like supernormal stimulus of this
extreme behavior at the podium,
right.
Attract people in.
And basically Hitler was saying,
I was talking about the equivalent of
extra terrestrials.
He was talking about this magic quality
of the Germans.
He was talking about the shared soul of
the Germans and how the people in Wagner
operas.
Um,
and the gods of the old Germans had been
in the souls of these people and he was
evoking the group soul,
the Zeitgeists.
Um,
the,
in this case is the Volk geist the
spirit of a people and the flying saucer
people are after an end of the world in
which the world will be remade.
And a guy named while there was a Jewish
kid from a backward town,
a really backward town,
and we'll only had been trained in
manual skills.
And he started preaching and he preached
that the world was,
as we know it was about to end,
and we were about to enter a new kind of
paradise.
And because he was Jewish,
he figured it's got to happen at
Passover because of Passover.
You put out a cup for Elijah and Elijah
is there to proceed the savior,
um,
the,
the guy who will save the Jewish people.
So he went up to the holiest city in
Judaism to Jerusalem,
and he had a dinner,
um,
the Passover dinner,
and they put out the cop and that's when
the Kingdom of God was supposed to
arrive.
His prediction of a kingdom of God
arriving at that particular Passover
ceremony turned out to be utterly wrong.
And in fact,
the Romans seized him and nailed him to
a cross and he died.
It was the opposite of everything he
predicted,
but the religion he'd put together and
the religion really that Paul put
together because Paul was an
international figure.
You know,
he was comfortable in the global world
of the Roman Empire.
But what Paul put together around Jesus
was a supernormal stimulus and it evoked
a super normal response,
a supernormal reflex and the flying
saucer ideas that,
you know,
here we are on earth,
but there's this brace that's above us
that can save us.
Um,
that's pushing at the same buttons.
Hitler was pushing at the same buttons,
the world as know it was about and when
there's a new paradise and while the
Germans will rule everything,
um,
so we are built to receive certain kinds
of stimuli.
God knows how we got built that way.
And when I went out in quest of the
ecstatic of God that God's inside of us,
that the age of 13,
I was looking for that super normal,
those super normal responses in us and
for the supernormal stimuli that have
oic them.
And when you're doing art,
when you were doing commentary,
when you're doing comedy,
you are hitting the buttons,
you are creating supernormal stimuli,
you are testing out jokes until they
reached just the right shape and you
know what you can feel in the audience
what that shape is and then you repeat
that shape knowing what its impact is
going to be on the audience.
I wrote a new book,
um,
it took me a long time to write all of
my previous books,
including how I accidentally started the
60s.
And by the way,
it isn't the same 1995 manuscript.
I had 20 years of additional processing
and was able to put a lot more meaning
and to the book and hopefully it's still
really funny.
Um,
but I was able to write a book in six
weeks.
The first draft of 178,000 word book and
a normal book is 90,000 words.
So this is almost twice the length of a
normal book.
And I was able to do it because I had
told all the stories in the book and I
had felt out how the audiences responded
to the stories and I knew the words to
use and they were a well worn path in my
brain.
So I simply put down on paper an oral
vocabulary.
But it's the audience who shapes you by
giving you feedback and eventually you
perfect something.
So it's like Niko Tinbergen Super Egg.
I mean,
newport,
Niko Tinbergen was a eventually able to
make egg super eggs that had dayglo on
them,
had polka dots on them that were absurd,
but they still had the ability,
the way that flying saucer myths have
the ability to evoke the sense that
there is a paradise beyond the world
that we know.
Don't you think when you think of
supernormal stimulus that when you see,
uh,
you know,
like a preacher on the pulpit that's
screaming with confidence.
When you see any of these things,
like even when it comes to fake breasts,
like you're seeing something like you
know what you want,
you want a woman to be uh,
good at bearing children,
right?
To have the right hip to waist ratio,
uh,
that she's a designed to breastfeed.
She has large press even though you know
it's fake,
it's still hits,
whatever that genetic button is inside
of your head and the alien theme,
the idea behind it,
the archetype is kind of like Space
Daddy,
right?
It's like,
you know,
I know we're stupid,
but just like this guy who is screaming
on the pope,
it has all the answers.
Like thank God someone has all the we'll
space
daddy is for the atheists space daddy.
It's for the people that,
you know what,
I've listened to all these people down
here.
I think they're full of shit,
but space daddy's going to help us out.
While that's the general idea,
is that what it is?
Yes.
And when you,
as I said,
when you fashioned a joke,
you're fashioning it to be a supernormal
stimulus.
But space daddy might be real.
Some were because we're dealing with
numbers as a science person.
Okay.
Um,
I have to tell you that there's only one
place in which we've ever discovered any
evidence of life and it's down here on
earth.
So I'm a skeptic about life being
anywhere now changing to a different
scientific perspective.
There's this thing that I call a super
simultaneity super synchrony.
And when the universe starts as a
rapidly expanding sheet of nothing but
space and time,
it space,
time and speed,
that's all it is.
And when it precipitates in quarks,
which is unlikely house,
how can space time and speed become
particles?
Quarks,
right?
Um,
the fact is that there are only
something like 16 different forms of
those quirks and there are a gazillion
of identical copies of each quark
everywhere.
And they all sprang into existence at
the same time.
Fast forward a couple of million years.
Galaxies all are pretty much the same.
And all of them spring into existence
pretty much at the same time,
at least the first generation of
galaxies,
stars ignite within those galaxies,
all following pretty much the same
principles.
They're all just big gravity balls.
Um,
gravity's gravity balls all the way.
That's planets,
that's moons,
all kinds of things.
So there is this tendency for the
universe to do the same damn thing at
pretty much the same damn time,
pretty much same damned everywhere in
this cosmos.
And we do know that there are bio
molecules,
carbon based molecules being formed in
interstellar,
cold gas clouds,
hot gas clouds,
all kinds of unlikely places in the
cosmos.
But those are very simple little
molecules.
Even though we call them bio molecules
is simply means I've got carbon life
depends on molecules.
In the case of your genome,
if we yanked just,
we took just one cell,
you wouldn't miss it.
You have 100 trillion others.
Um,
so we took just one cell from your body
and we took out the genome,
the,
the prompt,
what dwells to actually the genome.
So we took out the genome and we
stretched it out cause it's all tangled
up in the cell.
It would be three feet long.
So there's a big distance between a tiny
little molecule of ammonia in an
interstellar cloud and that huge,
very complex,
highly ordered three foot long molecule
or molecule,
a single molecule that's your genome.
Um,
and we haven't learned very much at all
about how you go from the simple
molecules to that incredibly complex
molecules.
The origin of life is still one of the
big puzzles,
but again,
because they're super synchrony and
super simultaneity all over the Cosmos
is pretty much the same thing happens at
pretty much the same time.
The odds are that there are millions of
other planets that have life.
Those are the odds.
But I settle out of side because we
don't have evidence of any life.
And we'd been looking since there.
Okay,
I'll tell you a story that seems to have
nothing to do with anything.
But once upon a time a manager gave me
an act to work with.
It was earth,
wind and fire.
And so I read all their lyrics,
I read everything about them,
I studied them like a Talmudic scholar I
always did.
And finally got to their album covers.
And when I got together with,
um,
the leader of the band,
Maurice White for lunch,
um,
cause I hadn't yet learned to set up my
boundaries and tell people,
only work with you if I can see you in
your own environment for between one and
three days.
That wasn't quite at that point yet.
I sat with my,
uh,
with,
with Maurice and said,
Maurice,
if I've got you right,
you believe that approximately 11,000
years ago,
people from another civilization
someplace else and now our galaxy or
beyond or a galaxy came to this earth
and brought us all of our technologies
and left the messages of their
technologies and the pyramids.
Have I got that right?
And Maurice Smile hold?
And he said yes.
And so I said,
okay,
there's this scientist from Cornell
University and he has just had a
tremendous success with the science
series on pbs.
It's the most watched series pbs has
ever had and he's trying to put together
an organization to find extra
terrestrial intelligence.
So if I introduced the two of you,
would you be willing to do a benefit
concert for him?
Because right now he's struggling to get
money together and Marie said yes.
So we tracked down Carl Sagan,
summer cottage telephone number and I
put together a conference call between
Maurice White and um,
Oh God,
what's his name again?
Billions and billions and billions of
planets.
Carl Sagan.
Yeah.
And um,
as soon as carl got wind of where
Maurice was coming from,
pseudoscience conversation was over
because Karl was already gambling too
much on ideas that could get them
totally laughed out of science.
So it was unfortunate,
but it's ever,
that was the early 1980s,
probably about nine,
actually.
Probably about 1980.
Didn't you want to just sit down with
Maurice and sort of explain what we know
so far?
No,
we couldn't afford stuff based on was it
was,
you know,
it's all kinds of,
it's everywhere.
You can find it all over the place.
What did it make?
Did he have like a,
a source?
Uh,
not that I asked him.
Oh,
I was too busy trying to put this,
yeah.
This thing together.
And it was unfortunate.
Yes.
It would have been neat if the two of
them had been able to sit down and talk.
But Carl,
as I said,
you know,
when he had,
because his first wife Lynn Margulis,
the National Academy of Science Award
winner and I became friends and she was
kind enough to almost mentor me and
Dorian Sagan,
Carl Sagan,
his oldest son has been a friend.
He's an absolutely brilliant science
writer.
You read his essays,
they change your perception of the
world,
period.
And um,
just by having the television show,
the people in quote legitimate science,
we're saying Carl's not a legitimate
scientist as a whole television show.
That's right.
Because he's getting more attention than
I am now.
They would never admit that.
That's really what was in their hearts
from people about Neil degrasse Tyson.
And I've heard the exact same thing that
could be.
And the question is whether Neil
degrasse Tyson was ever,
uh,
a scientist,
cause he's primarily been a showman most
of his life.
And you should see him.
Joe,
I,
when did I see him?
Uh,
he,
he was at God knows what event and why.
I was probably there because a friend
was giving a sold out lecture at the
American Museum of natural history and I
didn't realize that I'm Neil degrasse
Tyson was going to show up and when he
showed up on stage,
because I consider myself competing with
them because I've always wanted my own
television series and Neil has been
ahead of me on everything and I'm older
than he is.
So it's,
you know,
the little pieces of grit that we pick
up and carry in her shoes and walk with.
So at any rate,
I saw him on stage,
I couldn't believe it.
That man is astonishing on stage.
He's beyond your imaginings onstage.
So I went up when it was over and it was
buzz Aldrin who had originally
introduced us via email and said,
I'm the guy that Buzz Aldrin introduced
you to 12 years ago,
who's been emailing you every once in a
while ever since.
And he was in the middle of a whole
bunch of people who wanted to take
selfies.
I don't get a lot of graphs setting
more.
They take selfies and there were lined
up to get selfies with Neil degrasse
Tyson and Neil degrasse Tyson turned his
back on all of them.
This is not right.
This is not proper.
This is not polite.
In order to give me a lecture about how
hard it had been to make himself into a
showman.
And it looks easy,
but it takes decades of work.
Well,
I appreciated him giving me the little
lecture,
but um,
all these people were waiting for him.
But he is amazing.
So we talk about that incandescent
power.
When you go transcendent onstage and you
become an empty pipe through which
something speaks through you,
even though they're words that you've
thought out for years,
but all of a sudden they're speaking in
themselves through you.
Um,
and how it's the essence of the forces
of history,
that ability to give people the sense
that they've been yanked out of
themselves and are a part,
something bigger than themselves.
That's the super normal reflex that is
the most profound.
And it's the one that grabs history by
the balls and changes its direction and
earth,
wind and fire had that with music and
they certainly did.
They just didn't have it when it came to
the understanding of civilizations from
11,000 years ago.
Right.
That specialty.
That's why you and I specialize in the
things we do in order to add to the
collective mind that enriches the people
around us and us too.
That's,
that is so attractive to people to think
that we got it from somewhere else.
Why do you think that is?
Partly because no individual creates the
stone tool.
I mean,
there may be an individual who did it
first,
but then it takes off the way that
gazillions of particles of identical
kinds show up all across the face of the
cosmos.
It,
it hits the Zeitgeists with just the
right supernormal stimulus and all of a
sudden it takes off.
And we're all aware of the fact that we
didn't do this and we're all aware of
the fact that there is some super normal
intelligence.
Um,
but we don't realize that it's we who
are the neurons and in the same way that
a hundred billion our arts now 86
billion as the figure.
So you've got 86 billion neurons in your
brain.
Well,
I got news for your Joe.
The folks in science are saying that 86
billion neurons as you,
which is a bloody miracle and they're
right,
it is a bloody miracle that or Joe Rogan
emerges from 86 billion neurons working
together.
Bod,
you're more than 86 billion neurons
working together.
You're 86 billion neurons working with 7
billion fellow human beings and the
whole bacterial world and the plant
world and the animal world.
And it's all contributing to who you are
minute by minute by minute.
So we are individual cells in this
collective brain.
The way that individual neurons who are
individually quite stupid,
um,
are part of the collective brain that is
a Joe Rogan or Howard Bloom or anybody
listening.
But it's such an attractive subject that
you have these shows like ancient
aliens,
right?
I mean,
that's like one of the longest running
shows in the history.
Well because it,
because the,
what we,
we become is something larger than
ourselves.
It's much larger than ourselves.
And so there is something that's super
normal.
Um,
and we can think of it as something
supernatural,
but we ache,
we ache for salvation.
And I tried to tell people,
I have a book called the genius of the
beast,
a radical revision of capitalism.
And it says that there's an
underpinning,
um,
imperative in capitalism nobody gets,
although capitalists have to obey it in
order to make money and it's saved my
neighbor,
me messianic save a hundred neighbors.
You get $100,
save a million neighbors,
you've got $1 million.
Um,
and,
and the book talks about material
miracles and about secular salvation.
When I,
when Joan jets manager came to my office
and said,
look,
I've got the service,
she's been turned down by 23 rocket
companies.
Could you just as a favor get me one
line and cashbox that'll record company
and we'll sign her and the record
company will make her career.
And I had a psych.
Kenny,
listen to me.
Um,
once you get a record company,
your troubles begin.
That's not when your troubles in the
record company.
We'll throw every conceivable obstacle
in some inconceivable obstacles in your
path and you have to have a panzer tank
brigade strategy.
And if you,
if you let me do the strategy,
if you work as hard as I do,
17 hours a day,
seven days a week,
um,
if you do everything I tell you too,
I guarantee you will have a star in two
years.
What she's been turned down by 23 record
companies were where is there left to
go?
MMM.
Doesn't that means she should stop?
No,
I only said this to two people in my
lifetime that I will give you a star.
The first one was to the manager of a
band called Rufus,
which had a number three single on the
charts at that time called tell me
something good.
I trapped them in a limousine.
I picked her up at the airport and knew
we were going to be trapped in rush hour
traffic and said,
look,
I know your band has prides itself on
its democracy,
but if you let me put all the attention
on your lead singer and you cover my ass
with the band,
I guarantee you I will give you a star.
Those the only two times over resetting
the lead singer I was talking about with
this band called Rufus is named now,
see if you remember her name,
because this is a long time ago,
Shaka Khan.
Sure.
So did the prediction.
He did.
But are we off track here?
We're off track,
but I'm talking about have to do with
ancient aliens.
Like what does this have to do with this
desire?
These have to,
to know that we got our wisdom from the
stars.
Well,
it's not directly about that,
but it's occasionally you tap into
something bigger than yourself.
And occasionally I had visions and
occasionally those visions came true.
And so there's something super,
not supernatural,
but certainly super normal about being
able to have two visions only to one
with Chaka Khan,
one with Joan Jett.
Um,
there are ways in which we form a larger
collective intelligence and we can some
times tap into it,
but if we can't,
then we better believe in something
higher than ourselves or we have a hard
time making it on the face of the earth.
A very,
does this make sense?
It does.
I don't know if it necessarily make
sense in the context of people having
this desire to believe that we've been
visited by extraterrestrials,
that we'd been shaped and molded and
helped.
And that,
I mean,
uh,
I had a conversation recently and the
podcast with someone and we were talking
about,
um,
uh,
genetic inner,
was it theo?
We're talking about,
uh,
people being a product of genetic
engineering,
right?
Alien DNA being introduced into primate
DNA.
And where's the missing link?
And I tried to crudely explain with my
limited knowledge of us that that's not
really the case,
right?
We know how humans evolved from ancient
hominids,
right?
While we,
there are a lot of mysteries,
there are,
but there's slot.
Okay,
here's the deal.
I'm imagining that there is a higher
intelligence,
literally hire we humans have a thing
about how sure.
And we're not alone.
Crayfish,
half a thing about heights.
Lobsters have a thing about heights.
Lizards have a thing about heights.
Bobby dogs.
I have a thing about heights.
So in that we're not alone and look me
for a higher power in the sense of up
there.
Yes.
Smarter than us.
More evolved us in the future.
It makes it an architect.
I've always said.
Seems like what we're going to look
like.
Well,
if that architect has artificially
shaped our DNA,
then who shaped the DNA of the
architects?
The archetype.
I'm saying that,
um,
you know,
the large head,
the right guys,
the tiny body is that we're slowly but
surely becoming less muscular,
more reliant on our minds.
Our minds will get larger or sex organs
will be thought of as being problematic
and the cause of many worries and
clothes and wars and strife and that
will eliminate those.
And that will exist almost entirely in
our minds.
And that this is what we're looking at
when we see the gray early.
And so race seems to be a problem with
people wanting to pick sides and decide
which one's better or worse.
And so there'll be no more race.
Everyone will be one homogenized.
Tamala John,
what's that word?
Homogenize.
It was the other one.
Homologue homolog the whole log us.
Yeah.
What does that word?
Amala guys?
Yeah.
Homologous [inaudible].
What does that word I'm looking for?
Whatever.
A collection.
Right?
All the races brought to one form and
everybody will share this form.
So there'll be no pros or cons.
Nothing better.
And everything will exist in the mind.
So it's another version of the Kingdom
of God.
Yes.
And,
and it's strange thing is space daddy.
You know?
So the strange thing is that Jesus made
these predictions that the Kingdom of
God was going to arrive at any minute.
Right.
And the first Christians waited around
what's going to happen at any minute.
So first it was going to happen to any
eighth day now,
then any week now,
then any month now,
then in a year now,
then any decade or century now
millennium now.
And so did Jesus religion disappear
because it made a prediction and the
prediction didn't come true?
No,
not really.
So apparently the religion is somehow a
supernormal stimulus,
even though its predictions don't come
true.
There is something in us that needs a
higher something.
Well,
isn't the prediction of religion just
wait around because it's gone to come
true?
Well,
it's been very hard to justify that
after it didn't come true tomorrow and
it didn't come through next year and it
didn't to read the scrolls and correctly
that has the power to hang in there for
2000 years.
That's astonishing.
When it's basic prediction is utterly
false.
There's always a,
every decade or so there's some group
that decides.
They know when the next
William Miller in the 18 hundreds
let just a few years ago,
there was billboards all across the
country by some group that had decided
it was going to take place on a certain
day.
And they were like,
are you ready?
And you know,
there's the rapture's coming,
right,
protect these billboards out.
And then he came and went and many
years,
you know,
and then they said,
oh,
we made some calculations,
we made some mistakes and there's some
errors.
Well,
it happened,
it happened in the 1840 William Miller
made a prediction.
Everybody sold their goods and we're
waiting for the rapture and it didn't
happen.
So William o said,
I must have gotten my predict by my
calculations wrong.
Went back to the calculating board and
came back with a new calculation
calculation that was a year later and
amazing.
Remember those?
Do you remember those jeans?
I never saw them.
[inaudible] 21st 2011 he is coming
again.
Whoops.
So,
but the point is that William Miller
religion,
even after it got it wrong,
twice is still around.
It's the adventist religion and it's on
two different sacks in,
there are at least 22 million of them
planted around the planet.
And Michael Jackson and his mother were
Jehovah's Witnesses.
Um,
which I believe is one of the William
Miller based religions.
So it if you fashion the religion right
as a supernormal stimulus,
like those eggs with Polka dots and day
that still were able to outfox the real
eggs or out stimulate the mother.
Yes.
Um,
it'll last and we humans think that
we're all about rational prediction and
control.
No,
we're not.
But in the face and the understanding
that in the greater view of the
universe,
what we understand about the universe,
we are so minuscule,
right?
More we pay attention to it.
The more we,
it's just sort of embedded into our
consciousness that there is,
there is a vast universe out there and
there are so many possibilities and it's
so overwhelming that this,
this framework of religion or a cult or
whatever you want to call it becomes
sort of like a scaffolding in which you
can sort of operate inside of this
impossibly large thing that we exist in
and yet still have,
well that's a good hypothesis that it
brings things down to a scale we can
comprehend.
I think of it as almost like a a a
bridge to evolution of us being wild aid
creatures to us having language and
comprehension and this concept of our
position in the university being so
small and then what is the point of all
this and we'll,
we'll it,
let's give them a points that they can
make it to the next juncture.
Well there's a rabbinic idea and this is
from 1500 or something like that
probably in Poland and the rabbi said,
God,
left creation,
half finished show we should be forced
to finish the other half.
That's the version I like.
I like because it puts,
it puts the onus on us.
And God,
I wish I had my computer,
my laptop here because I'd read you an
epigram that I wrote.
That's my favorite.
But basically Jamie,
for all we know,
well it's,
it's in the laptop and your laptop over
there.
Yeah.
But um,
one way or the other.
The fact is every time we do something
new,
like inventing the smartphone,
which Steve Jobs did,
we add to the repertoire,
but we add to the repertoire of the
cosmos.
Right?
Because the cosmos has never done it
before.
So far as we know.
And even if there were civilizations on
other planets,
they be taking a path different than
ours.
So we are like the searcher bees.
Our entire civilization is like one
search or be in a possible cosmic
intelligence,
assuming that there are other living
things,
conscious things,
intelligent things elsewhere.
And eventually we will patch all these
pieces together.
But right now we're patching together
the pieces from
trillions more than true.
I mean,
if they're just a trillion cells in you
alone,
then think of all the cells were
patching where you got there.
When we bring together all the creatures
of the sea,
all of the creatures of the land,
all of the microbial creatures,
all of the visible creatures,
and somehow allowing them to influence
our collective brain as we influence
them.
Imagine what life would be like for
bacteria if they couldn't have you as a
vehicle and they couldn't force you to
get into your car and go down to Ralph's
and by low them,
those damn chocolate eclairs,
the bacterial world would not be the
same.
You have given bacteria,
new powers,
and they have given you powers you
wouldn't have without them possibly
powers that allowed you to evolve in the
first place.
Well,
they think it changes your personality.
Now the gut biome actually affects the
way you think about the world that you
live in.
So you know about some or another
shaping you.
You know about this illness that you get
from cats.
Now,
when it takes over a cat,
toxoplasmosis,
when it's actually what it takes over a
rat.
Rats are normally repelled by the smell
of cat urine.
And when toxoplasmosis takes over and a
rat's brain,
all of a sudden the raddison attracted
by,
um,
the smell of rat urine.
Why?
Because the toxoplasmosis spends its
life part of it in the mouse or rat and
part of it in the cat.
So at a certain point,
it has to drive you over to where the
cat is likely to find you in order to
get itself into the cat.
Now think about this.
How the hell does a bacteria learn or
bacterial colony because they think in
groups of 7 trillion,
um,
how do they think
out how to drive the rat as if it were a
robot?
And as if it were a tank and they were
at the controls?
How do they manage to evolve a lifestyle
in which they spent part of their life
in one creature and another part of
their life?
I don't another creature.
How do they know the anatomy and the
brains of those creatures so incredibly
well?
Um,
we have no idea.
We haven't even considered the question.
Well,
it's a fascinating concept because the
be the cat,
the bacterial colony has to actually get
into the cat's Gut,
right?
Reproduce.
You can't reproduce outside of the cats
gut,
right?
Which is just insane.
And so it has to figure out a way to get
into the cat's gut.
And the best way to do that is to get
into a rat and rewire the red sexual
reward system.
We had some Paul ski on the podcast.
Paul skis,
terrific.
Broke it all down for us.
And as he's talking about it,
you're just trying to imagine how long
this took.
Well,
[inaudible] one of the macarthur genius
award winners who said that the God
problem was a great book,
the Gospel Album,
uh,
how a godless cosmos creates.
So,
yeah,
we have all these mysteries I had of us,
but every mystery we solve,
for all we know,
it's the very first time that the cosmos
is ever pondered that mystery and then
solve the mystery and then turn the
result into a tool that is a hard thing
for people to acknowledge or even
consider that we might be the only ones
that have gotten to this point.
And that some say if human intelligence
and exists and we know it does,
that it is as far as we know on this
planet,
the peak of intelligence and least in
terms of its ability to affect and
change its environment.
Right.
And we assume that if something can
reach this point here,
that it's reached that point somewhere
else,
but not necessarily,
well,
it would be different,
but somewhere it had to have been the
first place.
And why wouldn't it be here?
Well,
uh,
in,
um,
James fallows new book,
he's talking about,
I think it's Dakota and there's some
river that goes through Dakota and on
one side of the river,
the culture is one way on the other side
of the river.
The culture is another way.
Even with all of our modern
communications technologies,
there are still differences and the
universe,
at least the universe in the case of
life and we only know of life on planet,
is constantly stretching out fingers
into an use territories.
It's constantly taking,
it's doing the opposite of entropy.
It's todd certainly taking chaff and
garbage and stuff that seems like it
would have nothing to do with life and
turning it into Pistons and pillars and
fuel for life.
For example,
we humans,
right now we're under the influence of
another end of the world religion
looking toward a different kind of
paradise.
It's called environmentalism and says
that we humans
are causing climate change,
but now that's,
this is a little silly.
We humans may be contributing to climate
change,
but climate change has been the norm on
this planet for 4.5 billion years.
This is one of those sacred
science subjects that's almost like,
hey,
you're not allowed to talk about
scientific.
Jesus cannot question the the ancient
scrolls
and it's an end times,
right?
Belief system.
Yeah.
Because it says the world's about to end
because of things we've done because
we've sin.
And if we simply sacrifice to the
goddess of nature to Geyer,
um,
the universal go back to being a stable,
a climatically stable garden of Eden.
While I got news for you,
this,
this planet has never been climatically
stable in the very beginning.
It wheeled around its access once every
six hours.
That means we pick any point on the
surface.
It was in this poisonous stuff called
radiation for three hours.
Then it was yanked into darkness,
which is equally destructive.
And the temperature would go up a
minimum of 86 degrees every whoops,
up and down 86 degrees every three
hours.
That's climate change.
Plus it was on a tilt and it was
rotating around the sun.
And as it rotated,
the climate went through hideous
changes.
But,
but this is
way in the past and when people are
concerned with what our role and what
impact human racist,
doesn't it
matter what we need to be after his
climate state.
If we really want the climate to be the
way it wasn't 1650 before the industrial
revolution.
That's our human choice.
That's biogenic in origin and we need to
acknowledge that.
That's what we have decided and now
we're going to develop climate
stabilization to my questions.
Those what?
Why is it such a sacred subject?
If you,
what you've just said,
even just questioning for a moment and
saying that environmentalism is a type
of religion,
climate denialist uhmm you could be
labeled with that and then people would
love to break it down in a very simple
one sentence statement and call you
climate denialist right.
Climate Change denialist that son of a
bitch and the next thing you know what?
People will repeat that.
It doesn't have to have any,
nobody will want to sign you anymore for
a book contract or anything for any,
any complexity or context in,
in what you're trying to say.
They don't want the,
the subtle nuance of what you're trying
to express.
While there was a blunt nuance,
we have to develop climate stabilization
technologies have taken Carmen,
I don't know.
The atmosphere is a carpet stabilization
technology than so be it.
But we have to develop others because
this,
this globe goes through ice ages and
global warming's it went through.
Answer is in technology.
Yes.
That's what the answer is always been
for humans.
I mean,
why were we born?
Look,
we have this chemical in our gut called
assist to Keenan and it only goes off
when we eat meat.
So we're bilty meet and it's a bonding
hormone like Clark.
Oxytocin brings people together.
Um,
so if you're having a good meat meal
with a bunch of people,
this is a chemical in your routes that
says these are good people.
Stick with them.
Don't tell the Vegan says,
well,
so how,
why if we were born to eat meat,
don't we have claws?
Why don't we have ripping fangs?
Why don't we have for,
cause we figured out a way to cook it
because we make clothes,
right?
Gardens.
We figured out a way to figure it out,
a way to isolate ourselves from the
environment in terms of housing and
view.
Got It.
Troll of fire.
You got it.
And that means that we were born naked.
We were naked apes for a reason because
we are homo [inaudible],
whatever that word would be.
We are the people of tools.
Um,
and we developed the first stone tool to
the best of our knowledge,
approximately 3.1 to 3.4 million years
ago,
long before we became modern humans.
So we were born in this peculiar way at
that is naked and without claws and
without ripping things.
Um,
after we developed the tools,
it took like fire and cooking,
which you just cited,
um,
to allow us to have artificial clause,
artificial ripping fangs to cook our
meals.
Um,
the big conclusion of a book that I've
just read on what makes us different
from a neural scientist,
she's the neuroscientist who corrected
the standard figure for the number of
neurons in the brain from 100 billion to
86 billion by actually counting them.
She says,
what made us human was cooking just what
you said,
because when you cook,
you have,
you liberate all whole mess of calories
and nutritive sources that are not
available to a gorilla that's eating
leaves.
And how do we know that?
Because the gorillas born with a pot
belly the size of a Franklin stove,
um,
because it needs is huge digestive
apparatus in order to handle those
leaves,
to break them down into food,
right?
While when you cook,
you don't need that huge got now the
bacteria or the,
the ape is not able to go very far.
The gorilla,
he's certainly can't migrate.
Once you know,
you see Jane Goodall and she is pleading
for us to save the habitat of the
chimpanzees.
Have you ever seen Jane Goodall pleading
for us to save the Habitat of baboons?
Never.
The baboons are the rats of Africa.
Baboons are extraordinarily adaptive.
They're extraordinarily curious.
They're always finding new environments
and figuring out ways to turn them into
food.
Chimpanzees don't have that quality.
The reason we need to save their
environment is because they're so dumb
as a group because the collective
intelligence of a group of chimpanzees
is so low that now that they're adapted
to an environment that's the only
environment they can adapt to.
Whereas baboons who have smaller
individual brains have greater
collective smarts.
Do you seen how baboons have
domesticated dogs?
No.
Yeah.
The divest domesticated house dogs and
figured out a way to keep the dogs near
them so they can be alerted to when some
bad intruders or in that's amazing,
crazy kidnap these dogs and hold them
hostage and feed them right.
And the dog's just kind of learned to
hang around them.
Well,
their ideal of hunting companion.
Yeah.
It's very bizarre.
Well,
we did once upon a time and,
and you could say very easily,
it wasn't us who tame dogs.
It was dogs who team Gos.
Look how well we treat them.
Here it is right here.
See the,
they hold onto these dogs that dogs
tried to get away.
Oh,
is that a puppy in its shoulder?
It's a puppy on the ground.
Oh,
I see.
And they,
they eventually stay with them in these
camps,
but they hold them hostage.
Look,
amaze,
dragging this dog.
Right.
He's not killing it,
not eating it,
but they have somehow or another figured
out that if they keep these dogs around
long enough,
the dogs will bark when intruders and
predators are near.
Oh,
amazing.
Crazy.
Absolutely amazing.
Really crazy stuff.
But remember that was,
we were just looking at baboons.
Baboons have brains smaller than the
brain of a chimpanzee.
If you've ever seen a chimpanzee do
that.
No.
Chimpanzees are not highly adaptive.
What's the measure of intelligence?
Ability to adapt.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let's see how we measure the
intelligence of bacteria knowing that
bacteria work in a group of 7 trillion
and have a collective intelligence
within that group.
And they have a collective multi colony
intelligence because they,
once they develop certain genetic trex,
they pass the tricks around and little
tiny envelopes for all practical
purposes.
Um,
so they're constantly sharing new
bacterial tricks.
So we are told by the environmentalist
the new end times movement,
um,
that we have used up all the resources
on this planet.
We have vastly overburdened this planet.
We are eking it out of existence,
but bacteria are 12 miles beneath our
feet right now.
And they are turning raw rock granite
into bio stuff.
Now if the task of life is to kidnap,
seduce,
and recruit as many dead Adams as
possible into the grand project of life,
who's doing the best job right now?
Who recognizes that for every ounce of
living stuff on the planet,
there are a hundred million ounces of
dead stuff waiting to be kidnapped and
seduced to recruited into the grand
project of life bacteria.
Yet it our bacteria nature.
You Bet your ass.
So what does nature telling us through
these bacteria,
you have 100 trillion more ounces.
Yes,
a hundred trillion more ounces or a
hundred million more ounces of dead
stuff for every living outs you've got.
And your obligation on behalf of life is
to do what the bacteria are doing,
kidnap,
seduce and recruit as many dead animals
as possible and bring them into the
project of life.
Use Technology to stabilize the
environment.
That's what we choose.
Yes,
and that is what we've chosen and but
people are not regarding it as a choice
there regarding it as something imposed
on them by a higher force.
Right?
No,
I'm sorry.
Gaya.
Mother Nature is not a higher force.
Mother Nature is a bitch.
Mother nature throws every conceivable
obstacle warpath and she can't help it.
Why?
Because our planet,
in addition to the fact that we are on a
tilted access,
so we go through a climate change called
summer,
fall,
winter,
and spring every single year.
And it's a pretty violent climate
change.
And we have a planet that's been ice
baller,
snowball or twice.
And it's history.
The fact is the planet is on a
trajectory,
on a path,
on a voyage,
on a mission that is scarier than the
mission of Frodo,
the hobbit.
It is circling the core of the galaxy
approximately every 235 million years.
And as it,
as it goes through that long voyage
around the center of the galaxy,
it goes through spiral arms of galaxies.
The change our climate dramatically.
It gathers something like a hundred
trillion tons of cosmic dust,
um,
per year.
And at certain points it goes through
clouds of cosmic fluff that triple the
amount of that dust that we gathered,
which changes the climate considerably.
And we go through a milankovitch cycle.
It changes the climate every twenty two
thousand forty thousand and 110,000
years.
Not Precisely,
but in that range.
So yes,
if we want to stabilize the climate,
take responsibility for your decision
already.
Admit that this is a biogenic decision
and then go after climate stabilization
technologies.
Yes,
try removing carbon from the atmosphere,
see if it works,
but in the long haul,
we are on a 12,000 year passage and what
school climate has been relatively
stable.
That's not normal.
The norm is rapid climate change much
more rapidly than we've seen an ice ages
and they alter so we better damn well
learn these things.
Now,
when I was in Japan a few years ago,
I'm in a conference about harvesting
solar power in space and transmitting it
down to Earth,
which is carbon neutral and a source of
such tremendous amounts of power that it
defies description.
There was a woman from the European
Space Agency and she said,
well,
if you guys are going to build these
giant solar harvesting farms,
these five mile by five mile raise of
photovoltaic panels,
when you see a hurricane heading for
Jamaica,
send down a laser beam,
lays the outer edges of the hurricane so
that you change the heat at a certain
point on that hurricane and redirect it
so it doesn't hit Jamaica.
So it goes harmlessly out to see,
well,
that's the beginning of harnessing these
things,
harnessing disasters as energy
opportunities.
Now have we ever done that?
Well,
what about flyer?
If you'd been the first one to start
playing with fire,
your momma would have told you,
look,
you see all those dead animals in there
that have been roasted,
a barbecued by this forest fire.
You want to become one of them.
Put that back where it belongs.
And fire saved us,
um,
at the heart of a jet,
at the heart of a piston and the person
of a car.
What do we have?
Explosions.
That's one of the most devastating
catastrophes we can imagine.
An explosion.
What causes this?
Very rigid and I don't want to say
scientific dogma,
but dogma in terms of the way you're
allowed to talk about climate change.
Well,
there are certain aspects of science
that our religion,
because we science people are built with
the same super normal responses in us
that the flying saucer people have in
them.
And that the Christians who still
believe in the coming of the Kingdom of
God,
you can't debate this.
This is not something like even what you
said so far is,
is out heresy.
Yeah.
A little bit of solute.
Harrison people would get angry at you.
Well,
one person did.
There was a,
an astronomer,
um,
who would go on up to Canada for God
knows what reason.
He wrote a book on the evolution of the
cosmos.
I thought it was brilliant.
My friend Eshel Been Jacob,
my colleague who was the head of the
physics department at the University of
Tel Aviv and the head of the Physical
Association,
the Association of all physicists in
Israel where they have some pretty good
physicists said,
oh,
Lee will talk to you.
Um,
he's very open guy.
And when I got hold of Lee,
I forget his last name,
but you would recognize it.
Lee sent me a note saying,
well,
it's a pleasure to meet you,
but that article that you are in the
Wall Street Journal about climate was
unfortunate.
Uh,
it was something a little harsher than
that.
Um,
meaning you have sinned and,
and I watched this movement developed
from the beginning and it developed by
using conformity enforcers.
Will that Al Gore movie tipped it over
the top.
It helped a lot of things that just
people had,
they realized they had,
I mean,
if you want a virtue signal,
you got to get on board.
Well,
um,
what really put the environmental
movement on the map was Earth Day and
the guy who pulled that off really
pulled off an amazing pr stunt that was
just an astonishing pr stone.
And if that's what started it off,
yes,
yes.
Because in the 1950s,
when I was the head of the program
committee at my high school,
I programmed in a guy who talked to us
about what was being done to Wales and
the pictures were horrifying.
This guy was a giant,
he was about six foot two and and it
always days that was really,
really tall and he was most severe
person I'd ever met.
He walked in without acknowledging me.
I had booked him at all.
He had a frown on his face that was
unbelievable.
He walked out with that same serious
frown,
uncompromising without saying goodbye,
without saying thank you without any of
the normal social graces and he didn't
have a name for what he was doing.
Conservation was the name of what he was
doing back then and it was Earth Day.
That put another word on the map,
environmentalism and that God
environmentalism into first grades and
second grades and fourth grades.
When kids are at an imprinting age,
when their brains are little relieving
fashioned around some of the key things
that they absorb at that age.
When we talk about impressionable,
we're talking about a certain element of
the morphology of the brain that wraps
itself around certain things and then
never lets them go.
And environmentalism was built to get
into the brains of young people and
never leave.
And eventually environmentalism
developed its own end of the earth
scenario.
It tried to develop one in 1968 when
Paul Ehrlich,
who was a butterfly specialist,
um,
said that by 1980 which rimmer in 1968
was 12 years away.
So that's like my talking about
something that will happen in 2030.
It seemed a long ways away and he said
by 2000,
by 1980 we would get to the point where
there were so many people on the planet
that we'd have to stand on each other's
shoulders.
There would be no room for us.
We would vastly outstrip the carrying
capacity of the universe,
meaning the food supply would run out.
It would not be able to keep up with our
population growth.
And as a consequence,
in the early 1980s,
people would die by the hundreds of
millions in India and China.
And even the United States now.
Rumor back to those days,
Joe,
I don't know if you know the history of
it.
You were probably born after it,
but did remember all the hundreds of
millions of people dying in India and
China and the United States.
Remember how your parents had a stand on
each other's shoulders in order to find
room to live and I don't recall that.
You don't,
what's wrong with you?
I don't understand so much like the
apocalyptic cults.
They moved the goalposts.
Yeah,
exactly.
And so now it's climate change and
originally it was global warming and
then they smartened up to the fact that
they better cover their ass just in case
we had an ice age instead of warming and
glass.
What is the planet of global warming and
climate change?
This one.
Yeah,
big time.
So they are right and they are wrong.
We need to do these climate
stabilization technologies.
We must,
I mean we've been doing them.
You said it best.
We've been doing ever since we invented
the fur coat,
which allowed us to get out of Africa
and go to the forest ends of Asia.
When we were still far from being modern
humans that uh,
the technology of the cave and beyond
that the technology of the hot,
all these are climate stabilization
technologies on a small scale.
Now we need to do climate stabilization
technology and our big soul scale.
No,
that does not mean that we have to put
software droplets into the atmosphere to
keep the sun from warming the surface of
the earth that we so stupid.
It's ridiculous.
It's not a reversible move.
But if you have a laser for her
harnessing space,
solar power,
and you use it to redirect hurricanes,
you can see what worked the first time
and try something different the second
time and the third time until you
perfect it.
You can't do that with sulfur docs to
droplets Lutsen the atmosphere.
That's one of the stupidest things I've
ever heard in my life.
But that's the first solution,
technological solution to come out of
all of their climate,
people's smells,
but we need to do what they're talking
about.
We just have to take ownership of it.
Howard Bloom,
we've got to wrap this up.
Very,
very enjoyable conversation.
But I'm having really appreciate it.
I having a great deal of fun.
So if you need me in the future,
you can get me on the phone,
which is how I do coast to coast.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
How often are you in la?
Very seldom.
As I'm on my own dime here and I,
while I would be happy to fly you out if
you're willing to come,
while I would love the comments,
do I look like I would ever say no to
your conversation with you?
Let's do it again.
We really appreciate it,
Howard Bloom,
ladies and gentlemen,
how much,
what time is it?
Hmm?